Das war's für heute.
Es gab?
Ansonsten?
Als?
Ja ich weiß ich hab gestern gesagt es geht heute um 9.30 Uhr los, aber was soll ich machen
wenn ich schon wach bin?
Ups.
Ah.
Headset in den Knoten.
Exzellent.
Woge bin ich, ja.
Woge.
Seid ihr auch schon Woge?
Nicht so überwächst mit Woge.
Hallo ich möchte Prozess Explorer starten, darf ich das machen auf dem zweiten Rechner
ist das möglich?
Yes.
Nein.
Fertig.
Da bin ich verboten.
Komm, darf ich den Prozess Explorer auf dem zweiten Rechner nicht starten?
Prozess Explorer, let's go, run.
Hat keinen Bock.
Desktop hängt wieder, mein Gott der zweite Rechner ist so im Arsch, lol, der ist voll,
der ist komplett broken.
Chat, ich mach mal kurz Chat auf.
Tiger Chat, ah ne ich hab schon Chat auf.
Ja moin Leute, mein zweiter Rechner ist grad voll am abkacken, ich muss mal kurz warten
bis der es sich beruhigt hat, ah jetzt geht's, ok, jetzt geht's anscheinend.
Der Explorer hat aus irgendwelchen Gründen gerade ein CPU Kern komplett blockiert.
Ich frag mich wie das funktioniert, was macht der denn?
Ah jetzt hat es sich beruhigt, ok, kein Schimmer.
Das liegt bestimmt daran, dass immer noch Avira drauf läuft, so alt ist der Rechner
schon, den ich hier zur Vorschau verwende, seht ihr jetzt nicht, aber da ist noch Avira
drauf, könnt ihr euch das vorstellen?
Ja ich hab doch gerade gesagt, also ich hab zwar gestern gesagt neun Uhr dreißig, aber
was soll ich machen wenn ich schon wach bin, Avira ist richtig Monarch S, aber sowas von.
So, jetzt, jetzt scheint es zu funktionieren.
Ich muss mal kurz gucken was ich da für ne Windows Version drauf hab, 3 Jahre nicht
geupdatet.
Soll ich vielleicht mal machen, auf der anderen Seite der Rechner fliegt eh weg jetzt, demnächst,
also warum, so, ich hab auch noch Windows Defender, aber der alte Rechner ist halt so
alt, da war noch Avira installiert, ich hab nix dran geändert, ne war ich nicht, ich
überleg grad was ist denn da drinnen, was ist in meinem Vorschau Rechner gerade drinnen,
ich weiß es, ich hab dazu ein Video gemacht, vor 8 Jahren oder so, ne das ist der aktuelle
Rechner, Sekunde, da finden wir, das finden wir, das ist es nicht oder, ne Moment, Moment,
wo ist das, wo ist das Video zu meinem Rechner davor, hier vor 8 Jahren, den da, den hab
ich jetzt grad als Vorschau Rechner, ja genau hier, einfach mal 8 Jahre alt das Ding, Xeon
4 Kern, muss ich mal überlegen 8 Jahre alt und ist an sich eigentlich immer noch ganz
ok, ne, rein von den Specs her ist das gar nicht so der Riesenunterschied zu aktuellen
Rechnern, ok es ist noch DDR3, mein Schneestellzwitz wird immer noch empfohlen, ja ich weiß
auch nicht warum, Leute ich hab ernsthaft, ich hab legit keine Ahnung, also es ist,
ich bekomm das auch öfters, dass ich auf YouTube mit meinem zweiten Account, ne das
ist nicht, das ist Bergsteigermax, das ist was anderes, hier den da, den bekomm ich
immer noch empfohlen, ich auch auf meinem zweiten, also zweiten Browser wo ich nicht
eingelaufen bin, bekomm ich immer noch meinen Schneestellz empfohlen, das Video ist halt
auch komplett sinnlos, ich lauf durch meinen Garten, so ich mein ich kann verstehen warum
das 1,3K Dislikes hat, das hat keine Sau interessiert, aber warum hat YouTube, warum hat YouTube,
ähm, jetzt weiß ich auch nicht warum das so viel, warum hat YouTube dieses Video jemals
empfohlen, ich hab keine Ahnung, ich verstehs nicht, aber gut, wenn YouTube meint die Leute
möchten jetzt den Max FPS Schneestellz sehen, dann ist das halt so, ne, was willst du machen?
YouTube hat sich damals gedacht, das muss auf die Startseite, zack, ich muss mal kurz
was checken, ne stimmt doch alles, hm, Klassiker wie Mozart, ja genau, so könnte man das aus
YouTube Algorithmus nicht sagen, Video an sich ist ja nicht mal sonderlich gut, im Unterschied
zu den Sachen von Mozart, die ja gut sind, die man heute kennt, mein Schneevideo ist
ja nicht mal gut, aber der YouTube Algorithmus denkt, das ist ein Klassiker, ja, so ein reiner
Vierkerner tut es doch auch noch ohne Probleme, zumindest für, für jetzt nicht unbedingt
für Spiele in der Kombi, auch mit der Grafik hat, aber für so normales Zeug, ist doch vollkommen
in Ordnung, ich mein man darf es nicht vergessen, der hat auch nur 6 Kerne hier, der, wo sieht
man das jetzt, hm, wo sieht man das jetzt, hier, konnte man den Taskmanager nicht so
umstellen, dass man pro Kern das sieht, ging das nicht irgendwie, man konnte es doch irgendwie,
ne, ne, ne, man könnte es doch irgendwie umstellen, Rechtsklick, ah, exquisite, ne, das sind ja
auch bloß, also gut, die meinen es sind 12, weil Hyperthreading, aber es sind ja auch
nur 6 Kerne, das heißt die Tafleiste Anzeigen ist auch Hardcore Debate eigentlich, das haben
wir AMD zu verdanken, dass solche Kernanzahlen in Desktop CPUs normal sind, ich rede jetzt
nicht von meinen 12 theoretischen, sondern von 12 echten, was hat, was hat, was hat,
was hat noch mal ein Ryzen 9000 für, ne, für nicht 3500, was hat, was hat der noch
mal für Kerne, 12, 16 sogar, guck mal, und der andere, der hat dann 12, ne, ja, 12 sprich,
der hat, der hat quasi dann wahrscheinlich 24 logische, das ist schon hart, das hättest
ohne AMD nicht gegeben, mit Intel, also mit Intel würden wir immer noch mit 4 bis 6 Kerne
rumkrebsen und 8 vielleicht im super Highend Segment für 2000 Euro die CPU, also da können
wir echt AMD dankbar sein, dass das so gekommen ist, wie es jetzt gekommen ist, not false,
null, ja, was aber, das ist auch so, so wirklich so, hier sieht man es mal so, Akt 2021, man
macht nichts auf seinem Rechner, na gut, nichts kann man nicht sagen, ich hab immer ein OBS
und zwei Browser laufen, aber trotzdem, ich hab, ich hab 4 Programme auf, aber es laufen
203 Prozesse und davon sind wahrscheinlich die Hälfte irgendwelche Chrome Tabs, okay,
es ist unter Linux gar nicht mal so viel anders, wenn man da mal ein aktuelles Ubuntu startet
und irgendwie ein Firefox aufmacht, ein paar Tabs, und dann mal Hardtop aufmacht, kann
man auch eine ganze Weile nach unten durchscrollen, so, exellent, was gibt's denn, ja, ich hab
hier, ja, ist echt so, ja, ich bin wach, ausnahmsweise, normalerweise bin ich am Anfang des Streams
immer müde, aber heute geht's, Wauke mit Java, das ist eine gute Kombination, muss ich sagen,
Wauke mit dem Java-Dinger, hab ich Java-Time aktiviert bei mir im Chat, Java-Time tatsächlich,
muss ich mal kurz testen, Wauke, Wauke, das ist eine gute Kombination, die gefällt mir,
willst du Battlefield, Tastatur, also ich bin ja gar kein Flieger, also ich hab weder in
Battlefield 3 noch 4, noch werde ich jetzt in Battlefield 42 großartig Flugzeug oder
Heli-Stells machen, und den Rest werde ich wahrscheinlich mit Tastatur fahren, ich seh's
nicht, ein Meter extra Controller für Trans-Sommer, könnte man machen, ich hab hier noch einen
original Xbox 360, was denkst du über die Wallhike-Spezialistin, das ist die aus Südkorea,
die mit dieser hässlichen Brille auf hier, die da, BF2-Spezialist, mal gucken, ja, gucken,
ob die uns das hier irgendwie ein Bild von zeigen, die haben auch nicht mal ihre Seite,
ihre Seite aktualisiert, je so, Pike, genau, die, all diese Brille, die sieht so dermaßen
hässlich aus, alter, wer sich, wer sich das, wer sich das überlegt hat, ey, das ist so
eine Brille drauf zu hängen, das ist, das sieht wirklich geil, richtig mies aus, und
außerdem ist das, weiß ich, das ist so low-poly alles, guck dir mal an, wie eckig die Backen
sind und alles, obwohl das ja eigentlich so die high-resigsten Builder sein sollen aller
Zeiten, die sie hier reinhauen, in solche Promotion-Material, also, ähm, ich glaube,
das ist gar nicht so wild, weil es doch sehr situationsabhängig ist, ob das jetzt irgendwie
was bringt, wo du dann beschossen wirst, also, ich glaub, das ist gar nicht so schlimm,
das hat Riesenwellen gemacht, natürlich, wie so ziemlich alles, das, äh, irgendwie DICE
macht, irgendwie Riesenwellen bei den Battlefield-Leuten schlägt, aber, ich glaube mal, das ist gar
nicht so schlimm, wir müssten uns mal angucken, wie es am Ende ist, also, wenn du das, ich
muss, ich muss ehrlich sagen, ich hab's mir jetzt im Detail noch nicht angeguckt, falls
es da schon irgendwelche super-deepen Analysen und irgendwelche Data-Mining-Sachen aus einer
Beta oder was auch immer gibt, aber, ähm, zumindest, wie das für mich im Announcement-Video
ausgesehen hat, oder, wo ich mal, ich hoffe mal, dass es nicht schlimmer wird, also, wenn
du es jetzt alle, sagen wir mal, alle 5 Sekunden aktivieren kannst, auch einfach so für Gegner,
die nur rumlaufen, ähm, dann ist natürlich fragwürdig, also, wenn das quasi ein Motion-Sensor
wird, nur halt mit Visual noch durch die Wand, dann ist es wahrscheinlich zu krass, aber
wenn du das nur ab und zu mal kurz hast für Leute, die dich irgendwo anschießen, Pfff,
glaube das ist nicht so wild, wenn in Battlefield angeschossen wird, bist du eh in der Regel
dead, von der Seite, oder, also du wirst selten aus einem sichtbaren Bereich irgendwie angeschossen
so nahe, dass du was machen kannst und der dich nicht direkt killt, also, ja, hier sieht
man es ja, ich, oh, das ist tatsächlich nicht nur Leute, die dich anschießen, irgendwie
habe ich es aus dem Trailer so verstanden, dass es irgendwie ein Gefahren-Display ist
für Leute, die dich anschießen, wenn das natürlich permanent ist, alle, oder, oder,
zumindest, ähm, Großteil der Zeit, dann ist es natürlich ätzend sowas, aber ich bin
immer noch unschlüssig, ob das wirklich so wild ist, ich finde es bescheuert überhaupt,
dass es sowas gibt, ich meine, Warlock-Scheiße brauchst du doch beim besten Willen nicht,
er weiß jetzt noch nicht mal, wenn du dich einer um die Wand stellst, ob der cheatet
oder ob der nicht einfach nur diesen komischen legit Scanner anhat, das, so habe ich das
nämlich verstanden, hier, so habe ich das nämlich in der Vorschau verstanden, alter,
das hört sich ja ganz verdächtig nach Corona an, ich muss mal kurz mein Headset entknoten,
Zack, so, ich glaube jetzt ist, ja, jetzt glaube ich besser, exellent, also, so habe
ich das nämlich verstanden, in dem Trailer, dass es halt Gegner, Gegner spottet, die dich
anschießen, das ist natürlich, das wäre nicht so wild, das wäre nicht so wild, so,
und wenn das hier funktioniert, ist halt die Sache, wie oft, wie lang, sinnvoll, tja, ich
weiß nicht, warum es so Zeug braucht, ehrlich gesagt, ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass es,
also es gibt, es gibt bei solchen Sachen ja eigentlich nur zwei Varianten, zumindest
ist mir das immer wieder aufgefallen, bei solchen Fähigkeiten, entweder ist es so game
breaking OP as fuck, dass es quasi must have ist und mehr oder weniger jeder spielt, oder
es ist so komplett useless, dass es niemand verwendet, ich glaube so einen Zwischen, den
gibt es da gar nicht, alter, was ist mit meinem Headset los, Krieg Anfälle, hier, kann es
mal einfach, alter, was ist denn heute los, so, mein Headset wird jetzt einfach mal ordentlich
funktionieren, Blitz, so, ich rauche nicht, ne, mal gucken, ich glaube wir müssen einfach
mal abwarten, bis das ganze rauskommt, dann wie nervig das wird, ich gehe immer noch
davon aus, wenn der grappling hook von Webster so bleibt, dass das mit das OPste ist, was
es in dem Spiel geben wird, einfach, dass du auf Gebäude kannst, wo teilweise nicht
mal Leitern drauf sind und du da zwei Minuten ungestört im Kreis rennen kannst und zwanzig
Gegner killen, ist schon krass und was soll, was soll denn beispielsweise, jetzt überlegen
wir mal, schränkt mich das irgendwie ein, wenn ich hier so einen Wallhack Overlay habe,
klar, wenn ich hier in den Containern rumrelle, schon, wenn ich aber hier oben auf dem Dach
bin, wo sonst keiner hinkommt und darunter baller, ist es für mich gar nicht so wild,
ob die, ob die da Wallhack hat oder nicht, kann eh nichts dagegen machen, ja, T-Work
ist all time low, ja, das war aber auch in der Beta den Bugs geschuldet, also das reviven
hat ewig gedauert, du hast teilweise gar nicht richtig reviven können, weil du die
Waffe der Gegner aufgehoben hast und auch ansonsten war das alles ein bisschen detached,
das stimmt schon, ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass das ein bisschen besser wird, außerdem
muss man auch mal ehrlich sagen, so richtig Teamwork gibt es ja eigentlich nur, wenn du
mit deinen Bekannten spielst, aber nicht desto trotz hatte Battlefield schon immer so spontanes
Teamwork, also ich glaube jeder ist schon mal kurz geswitcht auf einen Engineer, wenn
irgendwie Panzerstellts angesagt war oder hat zumindest mal Leute wiederbelebt, oftmals
nur rein aus Selbstzweck, also ich habe beispielsweise, wenn man Metro spielt oder sowas, ich habe
so viele Leute schon wiederbelebt, einfach weil ich wusste, dass wir dann die Stellung
nicht verlieren, was für mich auch wieder besser ist als umgedreht, also manchmal, und
das war halt das Coole mit dem Instant 100% Revive in Battlefield 3, du hast manchmal
absichtlich, obwohl du eigentlich nur quasi egoistisches Bashing machen wolltest, hast
du trotzdem 10 Leute wiederbelebt, weil du wusstest, du bist gleich down, wenn du die
Leute nicht wiederbelebt hast, also sprich, du hast absichtlich, obwohl du so der egoistischste
Spieler aller Zeiten bist in Battlefield 3, hast du ab und zu mal auf 2-3 Kills verzichtet
um 10 Leute wiederzubeleben, das war schon cool, also das hat gut funktioniert.
Also das wird mit der Wiederbelebungsgeschwindigkeit in Battlefield 2042 auf jeden Fall nicht
der Fall sein, es gibt ja zwei Wiederbelebungs- ja, Specialists quasi, die diese Spezialsachen
haben, du hast ja einmal den Sunny, also aus Deutschland, der 100% wiederbeleben kann und
dann hast du den anderen Typ, weiß gar nicht, ob das der ist, könnte sein, dass das der
ist, der glaube ich Quick Revive kann.
Quick Revive und ich glaube, konnte natürlich auch ein Loadout droppen, wie viel kostet
das Battlefield?
Es gibt wieder zig verschiedene Editions, die eigentlich bis auf die mittlere, also
die kleine und die mittlere gar keinen großartigen Sinn machen.
Ich glaube, das hier irgendwo steht, was der Unterschied ist, hier genau, so, Standard
Edition, also das ist ja immer das gleiche, also das einzige, wenn man will, man kann
sich die Gold Edition kaufen, weil, nicht unbedingt wegen dem Past, sondern weil man
vielleicht Early Access eine Woche früher spielen will, aber dafür musst du halt gleich
mal irgendwie 10 oder 20 Euro mehr ausgeben, ich weiß gar nicht, was der Unterschied ist.
Der Rest macht, also das lohnt sich finde ich überhaupt gar nicht, Digital Artbook und
Digital Soundtrack, das ist der uselessest Shit überhaupt, mal ganz im Ernst, wenn wirklich
irgendjemand sich den Kram angucken will, Digital Artbook und Digital Soundtrack, dann
geht er auf YouTube und guckt sich das an und das einzige ist vielleicht, weil du hier
irgendwelche super Skins oder so kriegst, wobei es ist wahrscheinlich auch im Shop,
also es lohnt sich nicht, also das einzige, was sich lohnt ist die Standard Edition oder
eventuell die Gold Edition, wenn man eben Early Access eine Woche früher spielen will,
aber ansonsten ist es eigentlich wurscht.
Was auch noch eine Möglichkeit ist, man kann sich genau, da schreibt nämlich gerade einer
im Chat, man kann sich diesen EA Game Pass oder wie dieses Teil holen, wie heißt denn
das EA, nee das heißt nicht EA Play, EA Play heißt das, genau und da kann man eine Mitgliedschaft
abschließen und kann das dann spielen, weiß gar nicht was der Kram kostet, allerdings
muss man nur so lange spielen, wie man die Mitgliedschaft laufen hat, für andere Seite,
wenn man jetzt sagt, hey man spielt das wahrscheinlich eh nicht so sonderlich lang, da kann man
sich für 5 Dollar mal einen Monat lang angucken und sich das danach überlegen, was du brauchst
EA Play Pro, ernsthaft, but why, das letzte Battlefield konnte ich aber mit normalem EA
Play spielen, na, she baited, würde ich sagen, das letzte Mal hat ganz normales EA Play ausgereicht,
das war ich noch für Battlefield 5, da hatte ich nämlich auch mal kurz EA Play gekauft,
weil ich mir nicht sicher war, ob ich das Game kaufen soll, oder was, Battlefield 1,
sogar, keine Ahnung, naja, gut, ich bin mal gespannt, also man muss ja sagen, auch wenn
man hier mal beispielsweise auf das Subreddit guckt von Battlefield 2042, also man muss
ja sagen, wenn die Beta 1 geschafft hat, dann ist es die Spielerschaft so ein bisschen zu
spalten, ja, also du hast immer noch ein paar, die finden es eigentlich ziemlich nice, und
du hast ganz viele, die haben durch die Beta, die sagen jetzt durch die Beta, also irgendwie
habe ich mir das besser vorgestellt, ich muss sagen, ich war, am Anfang war ich voll begeistert,
ihr wisst das ja, ne, ne, wobei, ich hatte ja da 4 Phasen, ich hatte 4 Phasen, was Battlefield
2042 angeht, ich habe gesagt, naja, das Game muss erstmal zeigen, was es kann, ich lasse
mich da nicht mehr drauf hypen, dann habe ich mir den ganzen Scheiß angeguckt im Vorfeld
und habe gesehen, es wird ein modernes Battlefield, was so ein bisschen in Richtung Battlefield
3 geht, und da war ich dann schon so ein bisschen begeistert, obwohl ich mir vorher gesagt habe,
hey, nicht so sehr hypen lassen, weil am Ende kann es ja immer noch kacke sein, so, da war
ich voll begeistert, dann habe ich die Beta gespielt und war immer noch begeistert, am
Anfang, ganz am Anfang von der Beta, also von diesem, wo wir bei diesem EA Event mal
früher, früher uns das angucken durften, da war ich immer noch begeistert von, wobei
ich mir da auch schon so im Hinterkopf gedacht habe, aber ich wollte es selbst nicht wahr
haben, so manche Sachen sind ein bisschen doof, so und seit, als ich dann die Beta gespielt
habe, 2-3 Tage mal, auch wirklich viel Spielzeit reingesteckt habe, dann hatte ich so das Gefühl,
ok, irgendwie haben sie ziemlich viel verkackt, im Nachhinein muss ich jetzt sagen, nachdem
die Beta jetzt ja schon eine Weile rum ist, sie haben viel verkackt, ich denke aber vieles
davon kann man beheben, paar Designentscheidungen sind immer fragwürdig, vor allem, dass jetzt
rausgekommen ist, dass ja Battlefield 2042 lange Zeit als Battle Royale wohl in der Entwicklung
war und man sich erst später entschieden hat, daraus ein klassisches Battlefield zu bauen,
und das merkt man, vor allem an der Map merkt man das und jetzt ist es bei mir so, ich also
gerade durch die Beta habe ich schon erkannt, dass die da noch einiges machen müssen und
dass das Spiel auf jeden Fall in einem vielleicht nicht so weichem Zustand rauskommt, wie man
das gerne hätte, da bin ich mir ziemlich sicher, dass da einiges im Argen ist, wenn
das rauskommt, es ist ja jetzt schon angekündigt, dass es wieder Gigabyteweise Zero Day Patches
geben wird, also das ist ja jetzt schon bekannt, was war ja auch klar und jetzt ist es bei
mir so, nachdem ich jetzt die Beta eine Weile nicht gespielt habe, ich hätte jetzt schon
wieder Bock eine Runde, weil eins muss man sagen, insgesamt, auch wenn viele gesagt haben,
das Movement ist sehr Modern Warfare lastig, ist es auch, muss man echt sagen, also das
ist das Call of Duty X Battlefield Movement, finde ich, was ich hier gesehen habe, wobei
Battlefield 5 hatte ja wohl relativ ähnliches Movement mit dem Sliden und sonst was, da
kann ich aber nichts zu sagen, das habe ich recht wenig gespielt, aber das Movement fühlt
sich sehr stark nach Modern Warfare an, finde ich, von der Renngeschwindigkeit her, von
der Slide, vom Sliden her, gut, sie haben auch so ein paar extra Sachen eingebaut wie
Bunny Hoppen und sowas, was ja mittlerweile, was ja ziemlich sehr runtergeschraubt wird.
Na ja, und jetzt würde ich es doch gerne wieder spielen, also die haben das schon richtig
gemacht, paar Sachen, also die grundlegenden Battlefield Sachen, das können die, das können
die, also das Movement hat sich gut angefühlt und ich finde auch, fand auch das Waffenhandling,
also es hat sich echt nicht schlecht angefühlt, aber es fühlt sich, es fühlt sich schon
sehr stark wie Warzone an, also wie das Modern Warfare Warzone, also sowohl vom Movement her
auch alles drum herum, also es ist wirklich ein, also ich weiß nicht, ob man das so sagen
kann, weil ich habe halt die letzten zwei nicht großartig gespielt, aber es ist das
Call of Dutyigste Battlefield, was ich kenne, man hat ja Battlefield 3 damals schon vorgeworfen,
sie würden sehr Call of Duty mäßig machen, aber im Vergleich dazu ist BF2042 noch mehr,
noch mehr Call of Duty, aber ok, ich mein, vielleicht gibt die den Erfolg ja recht.
Ja, das mit den Bots finde ich, das ist zum Beispiel mit den Bots ist so eine, ist so
eine Spielinterview, verstehe ich auch, und Bots finde ich mega beschissen, das wird sich
auch bei Release nicht ändern, dass ich das jetzt irgendwie gut finde oder so, ich fand
das nice, ich fand das nice, also nicht unbedingt das, dass du quasi, wobei das, wobei ganz
ehrlich, so schlimm war das mit dem Laser Gunplay gar nicht, die Map ist halt riesig
groß, was willst du, was willst du dann machen, willst du Waffen machen, die nach 50 Metern
nichts mehr treffen und mit denen du quasi die Hälfte der Map keine Gegner beschießen
kannst oder wie, also, und auf ganz weite Entfernung kannst du jetzt auch nicht mit
einem Assault Rifle irgendwie easy da die Leute wegbashing, also es ist, gut, ich mein,
das Recoil Handling ist wieder einfach als fuck, ja, du ziehst ein bisschen runter und
gut ist, das stimmt schon, aber was mir tatsächlich Spaß gemacht hat bei der Beta ist das Movement
und vor allem die Sache mit dem Grappling Hook, weil das ist einfach mal was Neues,
ja, ich mein, das ist natürlich für Leute, die jetzt aber mal Apex gespielt haben oder
sowas, die sagen, ja, dass du so Apex abklatschst, hat auch garantiert damit reingespielt, 100
pro, die haben es da garantiert mal beraten lassen von den Apex Entwicklern, 100 prozentig,
aber letztendlich fand ich das doch mal ganz nice, dass du Battlefield eben mit richtig
krasse Movement spielen kannst, hatte seine Vor- und Nachteile, aber ich fand's cool,
das ist jetzt auch der Punkt, ich würd sagen, das Movement in Kombination mit dem Grappling
Hook ist das, warum ich wieder Bock hab, das jetzt zu spielen, das macht echt Bock, was
ist Voraussetzung für den Ramp, keine Ahnung, weiß ich nicht, was nutzt du für deine Webseite
und die Weiterleitung, das versteh ich nicht, was meinst du, welche der Webseiten, meinst
du Kegway as a Service, meinst du den Price Jam, was, äh, was meinst du, nee, das glaub
ich nicht, also die Idee, das für Last-Gen-Konsolen auch rauszubringen, ist ganz klar Stonks,
was sonst, die wissen genau, dass PS4 und Xbox, ich spreche den Namen nicht aus, ich
weiß nicht mehr, wie die Xbox-Dinger heißen aktuell, ich glaub Xbox One war das letzte
und jetzt sind wir bei Xbox Series X, richtig, richtig, der Pains-Champ benahmung, aber das
war eindeutig Stonks-Entscheidung, das zu machen und es ist ja auch nachvollziehbar,
achso, das ist gar nicht meine Seite, die hat einen Mod gemacht, ich glaub das ist irgendein
Wordpress oder so, müssen wir mal den Sebaro fragen, wo ist der Sebaro eigentlich, das
hat glaub ich der Sebaro gemacht, keine Ahnung, weiß ich nicht, was das ist, war wahrscheinlich
ein Wordpress oder so, kein Schimmer, das ist nicht von mir, ja, die Last-Gen-Konsolen
haben halt große Installationsbasis, da gibt es halt Millionenfach, deswegen kann ich die
Entscheidung schon verstehen, aber vielleicht kann sich noch einer daran erinnern, mit Battlefield
4 war das exakt das gleiche, Battlefield 4 kam auch für Xbox 360 und PS3 noch raus und
ganz ehrlich, hat mal jemand von euch Battlefield 4 auf der Xbox 360 gespielt, die Version,
die ist so dermaßen beschissen gewesen, die Maps waren kleiner, die Maps hatten teilweise
weniger Details, das war einfach beschissen hoch drei, also ganz, ganz schrecklich, also
Battlefield 4 auf der 360 war wirklich ein absoluter Hyper Pains-Champ und ich stelle
mir das so ähnlich jetzt vor mit Battlefield 2042 auf den alten Generationen, ja, aber
dass das die Möglichkeiten stark limitiert, es ist alles eine Frage des Fokus, das mit
Zerstörung ist denke ich nicht so das gute Beispiel, du hast glaube ich eher Probleme
mit der Map-Größe und der Spieleranzahl und dann je nachdem, auf was du dich eben verlässt,
was an Hardware da ist, wenn du dich nicht darauf verlassen kannst, dass du beispielsweise
eine schnelle SSD hast, um irgendwas zu streamen, wie in der alten Konsolengeneration, ja, dann
musst du halt im Zweifelsfall weniger Details machen, aber du hast auch keinen Bock, die
Map in verschiedenen Versionen zu bauen, für Alt und für Neu und sowas in der Richtung,
also das ist alles eine Frage des Fokus, hätte man gesagt, hey, man entwickelt das
nur für PS4 und nur für Xbox One, dann hättest du ein ähnliches Game machen können, halt
ein bisschen weniger detailliert und alles, aber so alles in allem ist natürlich schwierig,
deswegen ist das einzige Sinnvolle, was sie machen können, das zu downscalen auf die
alte Konsolengeneration, die alte Konsolengeneration ist eh nur da, um mehr Sachen an den Mann
zu bringen und im Zweifelsfall dann sogar noch die Konsolenverkäufe anzukurbeln, weil
die Leute sagen, oh, geiles Spiel, ich will es jetzt auf der neuen Konsolengeneration
spielen, ich mach Upgrade inklusive Cross-Progression, also du kannst ja auf der alten Konsolen anfangen
zu spielen und das mitnehmen auf die neuen, ja, die Helden, ich muss euch ehrlich sagen,
ich hab's, also das ist wirklich, ich hab's, das tatsächlich war von Anfang an gesagt,
ich finde die Specialists vom Ansatz her nicht schlimm und das hat mich in der Beta auch
nicht davon abgebracht, ich finde die Idee mit den Specialists erstens aus Stonks Sicht
nachvollziehbar, damit können die einfach Kohle auf lange Sicht machen und wenn das
Spiel gut ist, dann kann es für uns Spieler ja eigentlich nichts besseres geben, wie dass
das Spiel langfristig supportet wird, dass es nicht nach dem Jahr der Ofen aus ist und
dass wie die heiße Kartoffel fallen gelassen wird wie Battlefield 5, das ist auf jeden
Fall ein guter Stonks Move von EA.
Das nächste ist natürlich, wie passen die in das Game und ich hab ja gesagt, ok, eigentlich
sind die, also bevor ich die Beta gespielt hab, hab ich ja gesagt, hey, eigentlich sind
die Specialists ja gar kein so großer Unterschied zu Customizable Klassen aus den alten Battlefields,
sind sie auch erstmal nicht, ich mein du hast immer noch Medic Engineer Assault Recon, plus
dass du jetzt halt Traits und Special Gadgets hast, die du vorher Customize auswählen konntest,
so, mit dem Unterschied, dass es halt nicht so ist, dass es mal so schnell geswitcht werden
kann, wie beispielsweise vom Defi auf den Smoke Launcher oder sowas, ne, wie vom Medic
Kit auf den Smoke Launcher, das war ja auch quasi, so könnte man sagen, ein eigener Specialist
von den Gadgets her, aber das geht ja nicht und jetzt ist halt schon die Frage, sind manche
Sachen nicht zu stark und must have, das ist eigentlich eher das Problem, was ich sehe,
also gar nicht so sehr in den Specialists selbst, aber hätt es zum Beispiel einen Crapling Hook
gegeben als Gadget für den Assault in Battlefield 3 oder Battlefield 4, dann wären auch 90%
der Leute damit rumgelaufen, einfach weil Movement das wichtigste in dem Spiel ist,
also es ist jetzt egal ob Specialist, also die Gadgets, also die exklusiven Gadgets machen
es eigentlich aus, ja und ein Nachteil der Helden, die seh ich auch so, oder der Specialist
seh ich auch so, dass es in der Beta halt so war, dass alles gleich aussieht, alle Seiten
sahen gleich aus, das, das war schon dumm.
Ja, das stimmt, aber ich hab da meine Bedenken mit Bots, also ich find Bots an sich ist übelst
Müll, ja wahrscheinlich in 2-3 Tagen oder so, die standen ja lieferbar in 1-3 Tagen,
die Map war nicht gut, das ist auch so ein Ding, was wir, also wo sich jetzt auch so schnell
nichts mehr dran ändern wird, also wenn angeblich Orbital, das haben sie gesagt bei uns, Orbital
quasi mit die beste und spaßigste Map ist, ich fand die Map nicht gut, also die Map war
einfach nur groß, ohne irgendwie nennenswert was drauf, das ist, Orbital ist so eine typische
Battle Royale Map, du hast so ein paar Highlights, so ein paar Hotspots und der Rest drumherum
ist Gelände zum rumflitzen, also das ist typische Battle Royale Map, für Battlefield hat mir
da einiges gefehlt, ja, du hattest das riesen Landefeld oder Flugfeld oder was das war bei
Orbital, wo du im Prinzip nichts machen konntest, du konntest nicht drüber laufen, da bist du
verreckt, weil sie dich entweder vom Haus gegenüber, vom Hochhaus oder von sonst wie
oder Fahrzeuge gekillt haben und es gab genau einen Tunnel, wo es selbst war einfach rein
zu gehen, also das einzige was du machen konntest, ist eigentlich auf dem Hausborn runterfliegen
oder ganz außen rum rennen, was du nicht machen kannst, weil das irgendwie 15 Minuten dauert,
also die Map hat mich auch nicht überzeugt, das ist so was, das wird sich jetzt auch nicht
mehr großartig ändern.
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass es Pupke, Pupke, alten Konsolen gab.
Die Battlefield 4 Beta, ja gut, der Battlefield 4 war halt übelst kaputt.
Ja, ist doch gut, ich wusste gar nicht, dass man das nicht durfte vorher.
Ich hätte gedacht, man darf nichts veröffentlichen, was den schadet, ohne irgendwie Zeit zu geben,
das zu beheben, aber keine Ahnung, was die jetzt machen wollen.
Ja, die Battlefield 3 Beta war tatsächlich ganz gut, sogar die Battlefield 3 Alpha war
ganz gut, mit dem LLV noch auf Metro.
Hast du mal Steam-Uternehmung benutzt?
Ja, das funktioniert, allerdings gibt es halt nicht so viele Spiele, die funktionieren.
Es gibt mittlerweile immer mehr und auch relativ viele im Vergleich zu noch vor ein paar Jahren,
aber im Vergleich zu normalen Steam-Katalog ist es natürlich immer noch wenig.
Nee, will ich nicht, ganz ehrlich, ich will kein Battlefield 3 Remaster, Battlefield 3
ist eigentlich heute immer noch ziemlich gut, was ich haben will, ist ein neues gutes Battlefield
und ich hoffe, das schaffen sie mit BF2042.
Ja, nee, ich glaube, es gibt keinen Rush, sie haben sich da so bedeckt gehalten zu immer,
ich glaube, es gibt keinen Rush.
Wäre natürlich doof, aber ich glaube, es gibt keinen Rush.
Rush war bestm.
So, was gucken wir uns denn heute mal an?
Zeigt mal her.
So, Youtube, jetzt hast du die Chance, uns auch mal Dinge zu empfehlen.
Neue Battlefield, guck mal, als hätten die mir zugehört, als hätten die mir zugehört.
Wo ist jetzt, um was ist da dran jetzt so?
Na gut, ok, dann müssen wir uns ja gucken, ist glaube ich nichts so Nices dabei.
Long range sniping is back, ja leider, ich sehe es schon kommen, dass wieder 50% der Leute
am Arsch der Welt rumrennen und snipen.
Allerdings muss man sagen, in Battlefield 2042 ist das mit dem snipen gar nicht so einfach,
es ist schwierig zu treffen, es ist schwierig zu treffen und es ist nicht wirklich reproduzierbar,
also manchmal bist du drauf und schießt durch oder vorbei oder sonst was, die Gegner bewegen
sich teilweise sehr abgehakt, was es schwierig ist zu predikten, wo Gegner sind.
So also, was will uns Youtube heute empfehlen?
Gibt es, gibt es da irgendwas?
Guck mal, geht noch nicht mal.
Firearms experts react, ja da kann ohne uns reacten.
China vs USA in Taiwan, droht jetzt der Krieg?
Ehe nicht, die haben da beide keinen Bock drauf.
Wobei den Chinesen traue ich alles zu, die Chinesen sind ja eh der Meinung, dass alles
ihnen gehört hat drum herum, das sehe ich keine Chance und was anderes öffentlich sagen
darfst du ja auch nicht.
Truck camping in a blizzard, warum empfiehlt uns Youtube auf einmal irgendwelche Outdoor
Dinger?
Sieht mal, sehe ich so aus, als würde ich mich für irgendwie großartige Outdoorsachen
interessieren.
Außerdem, ich glaube in dem Fall wäre so ein Tesla mit der Batterie tatsächlich ganz
gut, weil das alles was ich bisher darüber gesehen und gelesen habe ist, dass das wohl
eine ziemlich gute Klimaanlage hat dadurch, dass du quasi bei Minus draußen stehen kannst
und es trotzdem schön war.
Die haben da Gartenstellsvideos, denn fuck stimmt ich hab mal ein Gartenstellsvideo aufgemacht
jetzt denkt Youtube ich würde mehr Outdoorsachen angucken, das wird es wahrscheinlich echt
sein.
Playstation 3 mit Zubehör vom Schrottplatz, tja, zeigt mal her.
Yo Leute und willkommen zu einem neuen Video auf dem Teamus Hardware aus Kanal, ich habe
wieder beim Schrott und habe diesmal eine Playstation 3 Slim inklusive zwei Controllern und eine
Playstation Motion Controller gefunden, ja wie man sieht ist die Playstation 3 tatsächlich
ziemlich ziemlich dreckig, aber ich würde mal sagen wir schauen uns die einzelnen Sachen
einfach mal an und schauen ob die noch funktionieren.
Ich gebe mir jetzt einfach mal vor, Alter ist das Move, das ist das ist das Eis am Stiel
hier, Alter, Move Controller, der Dreck ist gefaked, meinst du der hat den Dreck einfach
nur so drauf geschmissen, dass es irgendwie, weiss ich nicht ob man sowas findet, weil
auch durchaus im Müll, da kann ich mir durchaus vorstellen, dass man sowas im Müll findet
und gucken was passiert, es passiert nichts, kann das Bild nicht scharf darstellen, ich
sehe das nicht, ist das nicht der Grund?
Okay es funktioniert noch, alles klar, easy.
Ich habe es gemerkt, die wird ziemlich heiß, wenn man darauf fasst also ist das wahrscheinlich
einer der Gründe.
Gut, easy, jetzt wissen wir auch Bescheid, dass die PS4 noch funktioniert und die PS3
noch funktioniert.
Wir moden ein DDR5 Modul und messen die Leistungsaufnahme.
Okay, das stelle ich mir nicht so spannend vor.
Dann lassen wir uns jetzt eine Runde von Level Capture Baiten.
Das muss sein, einmal Level Capture Baiting pro Stream.
Hast du eine Meinung zum Framework Laptop?
Jetzt muss ich mal eine Frage, was ist das?
Gibt es ein neues JavaScript Framework, was Laptop heißt oder ist es ein Laptop vom Hersteller
Framework?
Ich meine, es würde mich nicht wundern, wenn es Laptop.js gäbe.
Oder würde es, jetzt ernsthaft, würde es irgendjemand wundern, wenn es Laptop.js gäbe?
Gibt es anscheinend nicht.
Dann wird es ja mal Zeit, Leute.
Ich habe einen JavaScript Framework Name gefunden, der noch nicht belegt ist.
Laptop.js, auf auf.
Kommt morgen, gehe ich auch fort aus.
Ansonsten weiß ich wirklich nicht, was du meinst.
keine Ahnung, ist ein Modularer Laptop, das wusste ich nicht, kann ich auch nichts
zu sagen.
Aber ich glaube mal, es gab ja schon mehrere solcher Versuche von Smartphones bis, glaubst
du auch schon, Laptops, die meisten Enduser, außer wir hier vielleicht, im Chat, wir sind
ja immer die Ausnahme bei sowas, muss man sagen.
Ich glaube, die meisten brauchen sowas gar nicht oder wollen sowas gar nicht.
Die Streamqualität ist gerade auf 360p runter.
Tja.
Der Stream ist aber immer noch in 1080p on.
Okay, also was gucken wir uns jetzt an?
Das ist jetzt schon der Tag.
LevelCab, LevelCab, gbait wollte, habe ich gesagt, LevelCab, gbait also LevelCab, gbait.
Nein, nicht der Auer, LevelCab, gbait.
Jawoll LevelCab.
Ich wollte mir übrigens noch ein Highlight schneiden lassen aus meinen Streams, fällt
mir gerade auf.
Lul.
Ja, der eine Cutter hat gesagt, er kriegt es jetzt doch nicht hin, so nach einer Woche
oder so.
Jetzt haben sich noch zwei andere bei mir gemeldet.
Muss, mir noch seinen discord namen schreiben habe ich irgendwie noch nix mehr von gehört den anderen habe ich noch nicht geantwortet
Ich sehe schon kommen das wird nix all das ist wieder der wahnsinn
Hat jemand tipps moment wir gucken noch mal kurz hat jemand tipp welche mein kunde lgb alle für den einstieg gut sind ja habe ich
Also das beste ist wenn du es ganz einfach haben willst
Ich möchte nur einen eigenen loop den leds geben und in den struktur anscheinend also per infrarot willst du die steuern
Also gut da musst du dann gucken also die einfachste variante für leds wenn du das selbst bauen willst ist ein esp
66 zum beispiel sowas hier
hier zu kaufen
als controller
Kost kost auch nicht viel kosten drei stück zehn euro bei amazon und du kriegst bei aliexpress noch billiger
und
Als led keine ahnung
Ws
Ws 28 12 oder irgendwie sowas led strips
Da brauchst du noch ein netzteil und als software als software flasht du das hier drauf
Und dann ist easy as fuck dann gehst du aufs web interface
Und kannst hier alles einstellen was du willst guck hier siehst es ja
So sieht das what the fuck
monka
So sieht dann das web interface aus von dem ding
Also brauchst netzteil in dem fall 5 volt
ein 5 volt netzteil für diese ws
28 12
5 volt es sollte jetzt vielleicht nicht das billigste sein also so 5 5 volt netzteil ein ampere ist definitiv zu wenig wenn die dinge
Hell sein hell sein sollen also wenn die hier bei amazon wie es
Also wenn du die irgendwie sowas hier kaufst bei amazon wobei ich halt sagen wird das ist die billigste die billigste variante
Ich finde es nicht die schönste variante die schönste variante ist led sk weil die haben noch ein
Ne weiße led dabei sk. Ich habe aber vergessen wie das heißt led sk
2 ne sk. 6 ich glaube das da
Und das die
Ja die sind ein bisschen teurer die haben aber den vorteil du hast noch eine weiße led dabei du hast rgb und weiß das ist dann schöner
Wenn man eben richtiges weiß haben will so das in kombination du brauchst dann halt ein netzteil
Ich würde den 5 volt netzteil und dann irgendwie was haben wir 6 ampere mindestens wenn du halt ordentlich helligkeit haben willst
Ja so was hier zum beispiel oder halt auch noch mehr
Ja 5 5 volt viel mehr wirst du da wahrscheinlich auch nicht kriegen
Da musst du halt gucken dass du das dann aber auch nicht unbedingt per irgendwie jumper kabel anschließt sonst wird es ein bisschen warm
Aber mit diesem netzteil wird das schön hell und
Dann hast du led und kannst das hier einstellen du kannst aber auch mal bei mir im archiv gucken wir haben schon öfters mal genau
Diese kombi im stream gemacht
Beispielsweise letzten weihnachten haben wir leds für ein weihnachtsbaum damit gebaut
übrigens
Wo wir gerade dabei sind ich baue dieses jahr neue weihnachtsbaum beleuchtung
Und was ich mich gefragt habe gibt es diesen kram auch als kette nähe oder
Weil das ding eignet sich nicht für weihnachtsbaum das ist das ist mist das ist wunderbar ums an der wand lang zu machen aber nicht für
einen baum
Was nach bürger
was nach bbs led
die bullshit led
Ah hier
Ja gut
Das ist an sich schon mal ganz nice aber
Ich will ja irgendwas zum selbst ansteuern welche welche sind das
Muss ich mal gucken
Ja musik ist ist weg das sind voll adressierbar ja ich will die aber selbst adressieren also
Nicht mit dem controller sondern ich möchte selbst dass ist dass das machen
Was sind das 12 voll 5 voll
Weiß ich nicht
Muss ich mal gucken so wir gucken uns jetzt wir lassen es jetzt debaten von level cap
Wie kommt es bei dem japaner
Wie kommt es bei der zeitumstellung
Zeitumstellung
Ach kabelabstand und esp dran das geht sind sie fünf voll oder zwölf voll
5 voll wunderbar
Ja das wissen wir ja schon
Moment sec sec
Clustrates
Ja das war ja schon davon auszugehen
Das konntest du ja mit einem bug sogar schon in der beta spielen du konntest ja mit einem bug ich weiß ob ihr das gesehen
Aber es gab ja einen bug in der battlefield 2042 beta dass du als sturmsoldat von battlefield 3 spielen konntest
Was ich eigentlich recht nahe was ich eigentlich echt nice fand
Der im Portal
Ich fände es viel cooler wenn ihr im echten game drinne werdet
Wer hat sich jetzt mal eine frage chat ihr habt ja vielleicht auch diese trailer geguckt findet ihr nicht auch dass diese trailer
Schreien nach call of duty marketing die sehen original aus wie die black ops trailer
Kennt ihr noch diese black ops trailer wo die leute multiplayer gespielt haben oder halt die echten quasi die echten leute in den in den
multiplayer gespielt haben
diese die battle für die aktuellen battlefield trailer sehen original aus
wie black ops trailer
von der ganzen aufmachung her und sowas
Los gehts
An 느낌
Ge 이거를
ano
A
And that's good news considering how sparse the destruction was in the beta.
It's also concerning news for some players since Battlefield V's level of destruction wasn't as large scale as past titles.
The new pacific map called Dera for Call of Duty Warzone finally has a release date.
It launches on December 2nd following multiple limited time events and directly integrates the battle royale with-
Ganz viele Kertz, weil Warzone ja schon mittlerweile sehr ausgelutscht ist.
Ich bin mal gespannt, ob sie das jetzt hinbekommen, das rüber zu retten.
Quasi so diesen ganzen- Wie soll ich sagen so?
Dieses ganze Warzone Ökosystem, was entstanden ist aus Streams, YouTube-Channeln und halt auch immer noch vielen Spielern.
Und Cheatern natürlich auch in die neue Version.
The launch also includes Ricochet, which is Call of Duty's new anti-cheat solution. Obviously the Vanguard integration is a massive deal for the franchise.
This is the first new full scale Warzone map since the mode launch of last year, previews of Call of Duty Warzone, but it's also going to be a very different experience from its advanced urban setting.
Ist es der Ravensoft, man?
Ich hab mir nichts zu Vanguard angeguckt bisher, gar nichts. Also ich ohne Scheiß Vanguard lässt mich so extrem kalt.
Das ist die Stift-Kompetition von Battlefield 2042's Hazard-Zone-Mode, seit es die Map, die am meisten direkt mit 2042's urban-Settings konkurriert ist, verliert. Diese Weihnachtssaison brennt mit Unwahrheit von zwei der größten FPS-Franchisen der Gaming. Wir sind interessiert, was ihr erwartet.
Schreibt eure Kommentare in die Kommentare.
Gar nichts. Ich expecte einfach nur, dass mir die Spiele Spaß machen und das vielleicht länger als zwei Tage. Das wäre schon nice.
Apex.
Was soll überhaupt das Setting von Vanguard sein? Ich glaube Zweiter Weltkrieg, oder?
Das hat jetzt noch gefehlt.
Moment, die crunchen immer noch? Das ist bei denen jetzt einfach normal, das ist jetzt schon Default oder was?
Ich habe mir das Spiel noch nicht gekauft, also wenn ich mir die Roadmaps so ansehe, werde ich mir das Spiel vielleicht mal Ende 2022 angucken.
Die haben wir jetzt noch gefehlt.
Ich hoffe Snoop Dogg macht dann auch wieder Live-Gameplay wie in Battlefield 1, wo er einen Joint geraucht hat und zwei Stunden im Graben nach links und rechts gelaufen ist.
Das ist das beste Gameplay überhaupt.
Was sagt ihr zu Cannabis-Legalisierung? Sollen sie das machen oder nicht? Also ich bin ja dafür.
Oh, er tut ein Salary Card. Also das heißt anstatt 300 Millionen kriegt er jetzt nur noch 290 Millionen oder wie?
Wisst ihr warum? Das ist so geil. Das ist einfach nur, also man darf jetzt nicht denken, dass er das jetzt macht, weil er über Nacht die Erleuchtung bekommen hat, dass das vielleicht gute Sachen wären.
Der hat festgestellt, sie haben es jetzt versucht ein Jahr auszusetzen und es hat nicht geklappt. Die Leute reden immer noch drüber und Blizzard steht immer schlechter da.
Deswegen machen die das jetzt. Die machen das doch nicht, weil sie über Nacht irgendwie die Erleuchtung erfahren haben.
Das ist alles Stonks, Leute. Das ist alles Stonks. Das ist eine Sache, die muss man sich einfach immer mal merken. Egal was es ist. Wenn ihr Werbung seht mit, wir haben jetzt unsere grüne Seite entdeckt und sind jetzt voll umweltfreundlich.
Nein, die haben nicht über Nacht ihre grüne Seite entdeckt. Das ist einfach Stonks. Wir haben über Nacht entdeckt, Diversity und Gleichberechtigung ist eine super geile Sache.
Nein, haben sie nicht entdeckt. Die wissen einfach, dass man damit Geld machen kann. Stonks, denen geht es seltenst. Ich will nicht sagen, dass es keine Ausnahmen gibt.
Es gibt bestimmt die ein oder anderen Ausnahmen, die da wirklich dahinter stehen. Denen geht es seltenst um die eigentliche Sache, sondern einfach nur um Dinge zu machen, die sich gerade gut verkaufen oder die das ansehen steigen oder was auch immer.
Im Prinzip unter dem Strich, es geht immer um Stonks und sonst nichts.
Na Gott sei Dank. Wird ja auch mal Zeit. Nicht, dass ich mir eine kaufen wollte, aber Facebook Login war ja nur wirklich absolut grausam.
Okay..
mit dem asymmetrischen, kompetitiven Schuss, Natural Selection,
welches ein Halb-Life-Mod als Standalone-Titel war.
Das Spiel und sein Sequel zeigten sich populär zu sein,
aber nie in den Mainstream zu verbreiten.
Jedoch war Subnautica ein Smash-Hit am Launchen
und verpulst das kleine Indie-Studio
in den Superstar-Indie-Studio-Stadien.
Die Kaufung von Craften macht einen Sinn,
auch wenn die beiden Studios nicht wirklich angesprochen wurden.
und haben eine starke Geschichte
mit kompetitiven Multiplayer-Games.
Unbekannte Welten werden als ein einzigartiges Studio weitergearbeitet
und es ist unklar, ob sie an PUBG-Titeln arbeiten oder nicht.
Bevor wir unsere letzte Geschichte dieses Wochenende sehen,
lassen wir uns wissen, wie Ihr Game-Ride für die Battle of 2042 aussehen wird.
Habt ihr noch eine nächste Gen-Konsole gespielt,
oder habt ihr noch eine Upgrade-Parte für Ihren PC gespielt?
Ich würde mich sehr interessieren,
wie die Spieler-Base als...
Noch ein Bot!
Das ist so demotivierend mit den Bots.
Lassen Sie mich wissen in den Kommentaren.
Hat Valorant eigentlich sowas wie ne Story?
Oder ist das so Overwatch-Style?
Wir machen im Nachhinein irgendwas zurecht.
Und das war's für dieses Wochenende Game-Ride.
Wie immer, Leute, danke für's Zuschauen.
Und wir sehen uns beim nächsten Mal.
This is the Level Cap signing off.
Ich wusste nicht, was die wirklich bis zum Ende machen sollten.
Aber das war eigentlich zum Anfang.
Was machen die eigentlich mit Mccree-Stories,
wenn Mccree jetzt nicht mehr Mccree heisst?
Werden die jetzt noch retroaktiv umbenannt oder wie?
Wie läuft das jetzt?
Werden wir den Kram nicht neu rändern lassen,
was Sie da schon gemacht haben?
Ja
Invisible was was für ein ding was bekomme wieder von videos vorgeschlagen hier 100 prozent invisible
infrared death lay death ray laser
Was
Der typ ist eh durch der typ der typ ist eh durch von dem haben wir schon ein paar sachen geguckt aber das ist vorbei
Der macht immer so abgedrehtes zeug
Also ich hatte noch nie irgendwie das verlangen danach laser zu bauen aber hat ja jeder unterschiedliche hobbys
Ich dachte erst es gibt ein age of empires placement bis man dann aufgefallen ist wie kacke das aussieht
Warum ich ich das triggert mich immer so krass warum sehen alle aber auch wirklich alle mobile games vom logo her gleich aus
Die sehen alle so aus alle immer
Warum und wenn ich mir das schon anguckt ist es wieder so ein typisches mobile gelb wir bauen irgendwie eine stadt oder so so ein schrott
Ja ja würde ich würde ich auch erzählen wenn ich mir ordentlich geld geben
Und wenn das ja nicht immer wenn das ja nicht immer so übertreiben würde mit den
Mit den formulierungen drinne ex post wie konzerne ihre gelbe ausbauen
Und wenn das ja nicht immer so übertreiben würde mit den
Mit den formulierungen drinne ex post wie konzerne ihre gelbe ausbauen das kann ich mir ich kann mir das teilweise nicht mehr angucken das ist
Es ist ja nicht schlecht gemacht die videos aber ich finde immer so
So von den formulierungen her sind die immer so so superlativen mäßig also aber wir können trotzdem mal reingucken
Wo sind wir jetzt hier stehen geblieben überhaupt
Lull sind wir hier
Jetzt müssen wir uns aber erstmal den 100 prozent invisible eye our death laser angucken
Death ray laser
Nein nein nein kein vikingsclan nervt mich rumpf
Also was was will er denn eigentlich machen
Was ist denn das?
Sege?
Ist das das wo die Amis mit ihre lichtschalter in die wand machen?
Amis mit ihre lichtschalter in die wand machen
So
Kokona haus
What the fuck
Was
painstakingly mount a tiny lens over the laser diode at just the right distance.
I found it easier to just remove the laser diode and stick in a module with an adjustable
thread.
Da kriegst du bestimmt Hautkrebs, wenn du dich damit anstrahlst.
The finished product is actually really scary.
Not only is it invisible, but can still blind in a fraction of a second, and that's why
I wear laser goggles when I'm working with it.
Now to those of my viewers out there who are interested in experimenting around with
lasers, a powerful IR laser should not be your first project.
Ich würde überhaupt kein Laser bauen.
Easy.
Nicht organisieren, nichts mit Krebs, na gut, dann verbrennst du halt die Haut.
Guck mal, du kannst durch deine Hand durchgucken.
Ich denke, mein Blut ist super transparent zu diesem kurzen IR-Wavelength.
Okay, jetzt bin ich enttäuscht.
Es ist nicht so, dass das Ding nicht wundervoll ist, ich meine, es ist definitiv.
Ich meine, komm schon, es erreicht die Klasse-4-Danger-Rate.
Ich fühle mich, dass ich etwas essen kann, das mindestens 100x stärker ist.
Und jetzt, leider, ein riesiger portable IR-Death-Rate ist nicht nur etwas, das ich online
kaufen kann.
Das Info-Hot ist doch viel schwächer, schwächer ist nicht, weil du hast eine geringere Frequenz.
Oder Wellenlänge, besser gesagt.
Nee, Schwachsinn, du hast keine geringere Wellenlänge, du hast eine längere Wellenlänge.
Also wenn du eine höhere Frequenz machst, hast du kürzere Wellenlängen.
So rum.
Was soll denn da am Ende eigentlich rauskommen?
Also ich weiß, dass ein unsichtbarer Desray-Laser rauskommen soll, aber aktuell habe ich noch
nicht so genau kapiert, was da eigentlich abgeht in dem Video.
Ah, der hätte aber auch die Bauer-Wärmeleitpaste nehmen können, die leitet noch besser.
Oh, das wird meiner Katze bestimmt auch gefallen.
Ah, den Typ kenne ich, da gucke ich auch öfters die Videos von...
Was kommt denn da jetzt raus am Ende, ich checke es immer noch nicht, ich bin zu low-brain
für...
Das könnte original irgendwie aus Portal oder sowas kommen, das Ding.
Ok.
Weil...
Wenn ich Laser-Gaggle in einen Welten-Helmet fülle, möchte ich nur, dass es keine Chance gibt, ein schwarzes Licht in meinen Gaggeln zu machen.
Das witzige ist, dass ich dieses Licht überhaupt nicht sehen kann. Es ist komplett unbekannt für mich.
Die einzige Grundlage, warum ich es weiß, ist von diesem Indikator-Licht, den ich aufgeteilt habe.
Das sagt aber, dass ich mir sicher bin, dass ich einen Schuss von Licht auf die IR-Kamera halte. Das ist ziemlich verrückt für mich.
Auf meiner normalen Kamera sieht die Kugel sehr weich aus, aber das ist nicht wirklich der Fall.
Hoho, schreckt.
Was sonst? Obvious, was soll man sonst damit machen?
Wenn die Elektroden zu nahe sind, fliegt der Schuss einfach durch den Gap.
Sieh mal!
Monke S
Übertreib es mal!
Dude, übertreибth nicht so mit Reverb!
Amazon Kartor leuchtet.
Alles klar.
Das wollte ich schon immer mal wissen, was da passiert.
Ist ja mal gut.
Er erinnert sich jetzt noch die Slow-Mo-Guys dabei holen müssen.
Es ist blaues Licht.
Ich kann den Laser-Spot durch die Goggeln sehen, wie die IR-Visualizer-Karten funktionieren.
Wenn es nicht für das extreme Blinden-Hasard wäre, würde es auch als die beste Night-Vision-Flashlight
funktionieren.
Es hat die Potenzialität, Dinge auszuliefern, aber das wäre nicht sicher oder legal.
Ich werde also nur das Ding benutzen, um die Sachen zu öffnen, wenn ich zu Hause bin.
Das sind alle nötigen Dinge, die das Laser machen kann.
Jetzt schauen wir mal, was das Ding zerstören kann.
Ich würde da im Leben auch nicht mit rumhantieren, aber der Typ hat ja mehrere solcher Videos,
also mein Finger würde ich ja trotzdem nicht reinhalten wollen.
Okay?
Ja gut, man kann damit Dinge anzünden, wow, das habe ich mir schon gedacht im Vorfeld,
natürlich ist es eine ausgefallene Variante, Dinge anzuzünden, aber gut, jetzt wissen wir,
wie man 100% Invisible IR Death Ray Laser macht, das war wichtig, das muss man unbedingt wissen.
Exzellent, man kann in den Taschentuch durchdingsen, durch, ja wie nennt man das,
durchbrennen, durchschneiden, was ist das richtige Wort dafür, gut jetzt wissen wir Bescheid,
alles klar, 100% Invisible IR Death Ray Laser, so und ihr meint jetzt wirklich,
das sind 17 Minuten, 17 Minuten ist ganz schön lang, ich weiß nicht ob ich 17 Minuten Simplicissimus
aushalte, durchlasern, durchlasern ist ein gutes Wort, ja sehe ich auch so, durchlasern, rein da,
na gut komm, das klingt, ich kann das gar nicht beschreiben, das klingt immer so, was ist das
richtige Wort dafür so, nicht vorwurfsvoll, ich weiß nicht, die Betonung von ihm, die ist so speziell,
als wäre das jetzt alles so furchtbar sensationelles, dramatisch, ja dramatisch.
Ja gut, aber man muss natürlich auch sagen, dass Gaming mittlerweile viel mehr Mainstream ist als
früher, auch dank, was heißt dank, leider auch durch diese ganzen Mobile-Games.
Die sind leider häufig ziemlich ekelhaft und manipulativ, viel davon ist lange bekannt,
teils wehren sich die Spieler, aber leider wird es insgesamt nicht wirklich besser,
warum, warum sollte es auch besser werden, Stonks, Stonks,
jetzt trägt er, jetzt trägt er aber hier auf.
Ja gut, es ist ja so, das stimmt schon, alter MonkaS,
das übertreibt es zwar nicht so, der ist aber echt durch, den habe ich auch schon ein paar
mal geguckt zu irgendwelche Highlight-Videos, der ist echt durch, das sind 57 bis 85 Cent pro Minute.
Na ja, das ist gar nicht das Problem, wisst ihr was mich viel mehr abfuckt,
nicht gratis Games, die die Leute ausnehmen, da ist es ja schon zu erwarten, was mich viel
mehr abfuckt sind, Paid Games mit dem Scheiß drin.
50 bis 70 Euro ausgeben können oder wollen, Entwickler müssen sich ihre Entwicklungskosten
dann anders wieder reinholen, zum Beispiel mit Mikrotransaktionen, eine Option sind zum Beispiel
kaufbare kosmetische Inhalte, wie ein neues Outfit für den eigenen Charakter, die sind häufig ziemlich
okay. Also mir fällt zum Beispiel das Action-Rollenspiel Path of Exile ein. Ja, die verdienen damit ihr Geld.
Also ich finde auch PoE ist wirklich ein gutes Beispiel und auch ein positives Beispiel wie man
das richtig machen kann. Ich glaube PoE war sogar ursprünglich mal ein Kickstarter-Game, bin mich
gar nicht mehr sicher, ich habe das ja schon in der Beta zum ersten Mal gespielt damals, die machen
das wirklich gut, die machen das wirklich gut. Du kannst das Game spielen, du willst sag mal mal das
Game nicht wirklich ganz ohne Geld auszugeben spielen, zumindest einmalig, ein paar Stashtabs
willst du dir auf jeden Fall kaufen. Ich weiß nicht, ob es Leute gibt, die PoE spielen mit den
Standard 10 oder was es da gibt an beschränktem Truhenplatz, aber so ein paar Stashtabs willst
du dir kaufen, aber preislich ist das durchaus im Rahmen. Path of Exile übertreibt das bei
irgendwelchen Limited-Skins und sowas mit dem Geld, die kosten teilweise richtig viel Asche,
aber die brauchst du nicht. Die brauchst du nicht und ganz ehrlich, die viele davon will ich auch
gar nicht, weil ich finde das hässlich wie die nachts sind, aber bei Path of Exile ist es bei mir
eines der wenigen Male so gewesen, dass ich freiwillig gesagt habe, ich kaufe mir irgendwelche
sinnlosen Microtransaction, weil ich das Spiel gut fand. Also ich dachte mir, hey das macht richtig
Bock und ich kaufe jetzt halt was, was mir in-game gar nichts bringt, zum Beispiel irgendwelche
Hideout Maps oder sowas, einfach nur weil ich das Spiel gut fand. Warum berichtet Simplicissimus
nicht über die Abzocke der GEZ? Du meinst die Zwangsgebühren? Na gut, der gehört ja irgendwie
zu diesem ganzen Kram dabei, außerdem ist es nicht Thema des Videos. Und Path of Exile macht es in
sofern ganz gut, das muss ich jetzt auch mal sagen. Die haben zwar einen Shop, der ist relativ
prominent platziert, aber es drückt es dir sonst nirgendwo ins Gesicht. Du siehst glaube ich beim
Startbildschirm was und du kriegst relativ schnell den Shop. Aber du hast ja andere Sachen, andere
Games, die drücken dir es permanent in your face, diesen Scheiß. Das macht Path of Exile gar nicht,
was ich wirklich, deswegen finde ich es auch fair gemacht. Die Käufe sind einfach und klar und das
Gameplay wird nicht behindert, aber häufig machen Microtransaktionen Spiele aktiv schlechter. Ja,
die Frage ist auch nicht mehr. Also spätestens, wenn man so komische Ausgeburten hat, wie in diesem,
was war das, Battlefront 2, das letzte Battlefront 2 Remake oder New NG, dass du 1000 Stunden
grinden musstest um was zu bekommen oder einfach nur in den Shop gehen kannst, da sieht man
eindeutig, dass das auch rein kosmetische Sachen oder eben, ja gut das war noch nicht mal rein
kosmetisch, das war eine Helen in Battlefront 2, dass das auch Auswirkungen haben kann. Also das ist,
was viele Leute sagen, ja du kannst es dir ja alles erspielen, das ist, das ist so, das ist
ziemliche Mogelpackung. Okay, wir haben diese Idee, dieses Spiel. Ja, warum haben die Battlefront 2
gefixt? Nicht weil sie so nette Menschen sind, die haben Battlefront 2 gefixt, weil der Aufschrei
der Spieler riesengroß war und danach Disney gesagt hat, wir möchten nicht mit dem Ausnehmen von
Kindern in Verbindung gebracht werden, also nicht weil sie so gute Menschen sind, klar und viele
Games ist halt, der Aufschrei ist eigentlich immer nur am Anfang relativ groß, wenn mal einer wieder
was besonders Dreistes versucht. Guck mal, wie weit wir gekommen sind die letzten zehn Jahre von, man
regt sich auf, sobald es was gibt in einem Paid Spiel zu, man nimmt es eigentlich schon an, dass
auch in bezahlten Spielen sowas drin ist. Es hat sich die letzten zehn Jahre viel getan, Sachen, worüber die
Leute auf die Barrikaden gegangen wären, sind heute vollkommen normal und jucken keinen mehr.
Geld verdienen, sondern wie muss mein Spiel designt sein, damit es möglichst viel Geld einbucht. Viel von
dem, was jetzt kommt, kennt ihr vielleicht schon aus eigenen Erfahrungen, aber es lohnt sich,
die diversen Strategien der Entwickler einmal wirklich vor Augen zu führen. Erst mal verschleiern
viele Spiele die tatsächlichen Europreise durch Ingame Währungen. Und nicht nur eine Ingame Währung,
die haben ja teilweise drei, vier, fünf, zehn Ingame Währungen, wo du nicht mal durchblickst,
was auch Absicht ist. Mit denen ich 14 Splitter kaufen kann und eine neue Frisur für meinen
Charakter kostet drei Splitter. Wie viel kostet der Haarschnitt in Euro? 80 Gems, 13 Splitter
kriege ich dafür und sechs kostet die Frisur. Five-Hat-Time. Keine Ahnung, ich habe es auch nicht.
So entkoppelt man Dinge im Ingame Shop, soweit es geht von ihrem echten Preis, um das Geld
ausgeben zu erleichtern. Aber das ist nur der Anfang. Ja, das ist klar. Du willst ja,
dass die Leute durch Payment ihren Scheiß kriegen, nicht durchkönnen. Das ist ein Ausschnitt
eines berühmt-berüchtigten Vortrages eines Mobile-Spiele-Entwicklers darüber, wie man,
naja, seine Spieler am besten austrickst und ausnimmt. Regel Nummer eins, mit reinem Können
sollten Spieler im Game auf keinen Fall allzu weit kommen. Hier betritt Pay to Win die Bühne. Wer
extra zahlt, zum Beispiel für spezielle Items, hat einen Vorteil. Das raubt aber vielen schnell
den Spaß, wenn man es als Entwickler übertreibt. Pay to Progress ist da häufig effektiver. Am
Anfang geht alles ganz schnell im Spiel. Man kommt gut voran, das Dorf... Ja, das ist typisches
Mobile-Game. Aber dann, damn. Plötzlich geht alles super langsam. Elendige, sich immer
wiederholende Aufgaben im Spiel werden immer elendiger. Man muss 30 Minuten warten, bis sich
eine Ressource... Deswegen sehen ja auch alle Mobile-Games gleich aus. Also 90 Prozent der
Mobile-Games sind ja solche Abklatsch-Aufbau-Dinger.... wieder aufwüllt, um weiter spielen zu können,
oder man zahlt halt zwei Euro. Und wer einmal damit anfängt, dem fällt jeder weitere Kauf
einfacher. Neben undurchschaubaren Wechselkursen setzt man dann absurd hohe Preise für Gegenstände,
um zum richtigen Zeitpunkt ein Angebot mit einem deutlich niedrigeren Preis... Ja,
Chat, Chat, ich frag mich genauso wie ihr, wer diesen Scheiß spielt, aber es gibt leider genug...
Wir vielleicht nicht. Deswegen, Mobile-Games. Mir fällt sogar schwierig, Spiele dazu zu sagen.
Ganz ehrlich, Mobile-Spiele sind zum größten Teil keine Spiele. Mobile-Spiele sind eigentlich
irgendein... Wie soll man das nennen? Sandkasten, Warteschlagn-Simulator... Also Sandkasten, das
hat ja noch Anschein von Sandbox, das ist ja ein kompletter Gegenteil davon. Ich meine,
das ist quasi so... Irgendwie ist es ein Warteschlagn-Simulator ohne Gameplay,
sind die meisten Mobile-Games. Die meisten Mobile-Games haben kein Gameplay. Die haben
im Prinzip 100 Menüs, wo man irgendwas an Fake-Progress machen kann, der am Ende aber
keine Auswirkung hat, weil es kein eigentliches Gameplay gibt. Das sind die meisten Mobile-Games.
Es gibt durchaus Mobile-Games, da ist das nicht so, aber der größten Teil der Mobile-Games ist so.
Diese ganzen Aufbau-Fake-Aufbau-Spiele, wo man denkt, man baut irgendwas auf,
was aber eigentlich nie so wirklich auf irgendetwas rausläuft, die sind alle so.
Plötzlich sind 15 Euro für irgendeinen Scheiß in einem Handyspiel ein guter Deal,
weil Discount, das nennt man Anchoring. Macht das Angebot noch zeitlich befristet und...
Dann das machen sie ja alle. Und daneben da noch was, was eigentlich fast genauso gut ist,
aber weniger kostet. Dann sagen die Leute, ja okay, warum soll ich das kaufen für 30 Euro,
wenn ich das für 2 Euro kaufen kann? Das ist auch ein beliebter Trick.
Dann setzt man Bezahloptionen ganz gezielt, wenn die Frustration am höchsten ist,
um die Irrationalität, den Hot-State des Spielers auszunutzen. Ach, schon wieder tot? Willst du
nicht für nur 138 Gold wiederbelebt werden? Das verleitet natürlich dazu, das eigene Spiel
so zu designen, dass es diese Frustrationsmomente immer und immer und immer wieder gibt. Und
selbstverständlich nutzen viele Spiele all diese Techniken gleichzeitig.
Der darf natürlich nicht fehlen. Ja, sag ich ja, ein Warteschlagn-Simulator.
Es hat kein Gameplay. Deswegen finde ich es immer dumm,
weil man es am Mobile-Spiele. Es gibt natürlich wirklich was mit Games,
was man Spiele nennen kann. Aber die meisten Mobile-Games sind keine Spiele in dem Sinn.
Die haben kein Gameplay. Ja, Nintendo muss ja irgendwie Geld verdienen,
nachdem sie sonst gerade nicht so viel auf die Reihkrieg.
Wisst ihr, was mich da besonders dran nervt? Es ist ja die Entscheidung des Herstellers,
das zu machen. Und es ist letztendlich die Entscheidung der Spieler, das zu spielen.
Meinetwegen. Okay, ich finde es zwar nicht gut, aber meinetwegen. Was mich abfuckt,
ist, wenn Leute dann sagen, siehst du, ist doch gar nicht so schlimm. Du kannst alles
selbst freischalten, ohne auch nur einen Cent zu bezahlen. Was natürlich offensichtlicher
Schwachsinn ist. Ich meine, gibst 120 Euro aus, hast du fort oder musst 480 Tage warten.
Kann mir doch keiner erzählen, dass das irgendwie angemessen ist vom Verhältnis her.
Das Spiel ist absichtlich langsam gemacht, dass du das kaufst. Was mich richtig nervt,
ist, dass es so viele Leute gibt, die diesen Scheiß verteidigen. Und dann sagen, siehst
du, ist doch gar nicht so schlimm. Das Pokémon oder 120 Euro. Geil. Siehe dazu
dieses Video von Game Two.
dann spiel es doch einfach. Ja, das ist auch beliebt. Die Spiele tun ja auch
alles dafür, dass du trotzdem weiter spielen willst. Wenn es so einfach wäre mit, dann
spiel es doch einfach nicht. Vor allem, wenn man zum Beispiel großer Pokémon-Fan ist.
Die nutzen das ja gerade aus. Was meint ihr, warum es letztendlich den Herr der Ringe
Mobile Game gegeben hat? Bestimmt nicht, weil die Welt danach geschrien hat und gesagt,
wir wollen ein neues Herr der Ringe Mobile Game, aber einfach weil sich das mit dieser
Lizenz gut verkauft. Es kann halt einfach immer noch viele Fanboys.
Die haben ja auch viele Fans dahinter. Und am Ende, oh ja, das ist das Herr der Ringe
einmal. Genau, dann denkst du sonst was und dann ist es im Prinzip ein weiterer Warteschlangensimulator.
Diese Techniken sind bei Handyspielen quasi Standard. Sie werden oft einfach akzeptiert.
Aber allein das ist schon bitter, wenn man mal drüber nachdenkt. Der Mobile Gaming-Markt
ist schon seit Jahren der mit Abstand größte Teil der Industrie.
Ja, weil jeder voll Noob halt Mobile-Kram spielt. Guck mal, meint ihr ernsthaft die
Hausfrau? Sorry, wir sind 2000. Es könnte auch der Haus-Mann sein oder Haus-MWD, keine
Ahnung, ist ja auch legal dafür, dass der sonst nichts mit Spielen am Hut hat. Der wird
nicht das neue Battlefield kaufen. Aber der kauft sich irgendwelche komischen In-Game-Sachen
in Clash of Clans oder dem Herr der Ringe MMORPG, Shadow Legends oder sonst was. Der
weiß noch nicht mal, dass Battlefield existiert, zum Beispiel. Aber diesen Mobile-Scheiß den
kennen sie. Ich habe ja auch vor einer Weile gesagt, wo Belgien glaube ich angefangen hat
den Kram zu verbieten mit Lootboxen und sowas. Ich glaube ich habe sogar in einem Video gesagt,
das wird ja nicht dazu führen, dass die Hersteller das jetzt nicht mehr machen. Das wird einfach
anders verpackt und im schlimmsten Fall trägt es dazu bei, dass es noch besser versteckt
ist und quasi noch effektiver. Ja, natürlich.
Ja und du hast auch viele Leute, ich weiß nicht, da gibt es irgendwie ein spezielles
Wort für. Du hast auch viele Leute, die geben 100 Euro für Lootboxen aus und jetzt stehen
sie und haben was weiß ich, nur die Hälfte bekommen von dem, was sie haben wollen oder
keine Ahnung. Die suchen 5 Items, haben 1 davon bekommen und jetzt sagen die Leute,
hey, ich habe jetzt schon 100 Euro ausgegeben, jetzt wäre es ja blöd nicht nochmal 100
Euro auszugeben für das andere Zeug. Und wenn es dann immer noch klappt, jetzt habe ich
ja schon 200 Euro ausgegeben. Jetzt habe ich das ja ganz umsonst reingesteckt. Jetzt habe
ich ja ganz umsonst 200 Euro reingesteckt. Jetzt kann ich auch nochmal 100 Euro und dann
bekomme ich drauf ausgeben. Das ist ein bisschen, der Vergleich hinkt jetzt ein bisschen, muss
ich jetzt aber sagen. Das ist so ein bisschen wie damals, wo Leute sich eine PS3 gekauft
haben zum Online-Spielen und dann festgestellt haben, dass die Xbox was online angeht, obwohl
sie gekostet hat, aber das bessere System ist. Du hattest dann die Möglichkeit zu sagen
fuck, vielleicht gebe ich es zurück, vielleicht war es keine gute Idee fürs Online-Spielen
eine PS3 zu kaufen, ich bin lieber eine Xbox. Also du hättest das einsehen können oder
du gehst einfach komplett steil unter jegliche YouTube-Videos, die behaupten die Xbox ist
besser und verteidigt, dass die PS3 das beste ist, was seid geschnitten Brot. Du willst
es einfach nicht wahrhaben, dass du 300 Euro in den Sand gesetzt hast, die sich nicht eignen
für das, was du machen willst. Es ist aber bei vielen Sachen so, wenn du 10 Jahre lang,
was weiß ich, stellt euch mal vor, ihr seid 10 Jahre lang Mitglied in irgendeinem Verein
oder was weiß ich, ihr spielt irgendwie 10 Jahre lang Lotto oder irgendwas, gebt da Geld
dafür aus, dann ist die Versuchung zu sagen, ich mache weiter einfach größer, weil man
im Hinterkopf sich denkt, guck mal, wenn ich jetzt da einfach mit aufhöre, dann stelle
ich ja in Frage, ob ich mich die letzten 10 Jahre irgendwie richtig verhalten habe oder
sinnvoll verhalten habe. Wenn ich einfach weiter mache, muss ich mir da keine Gedanken
drüber machen. Ich glaube, das spielt alles so in diese Richtung rein. Gramex danke schon
für den Sub, Rico auch danke für den Sub, sorry für all die, die ich übersehen habe.
Es ist eigentlich, es sind eigentlich Slot und Casino Streams auf Twitch noch erlaubt.
Das geht, das geht so an mir vorbei.
Was, es gibt derzeit eine Kontroverse um Montana Black? Ich frage mich eher, wann es mal keine
Kontroverse um Montana Black gibt. Der Normalzustand ist doch eigentlich, dass da wieder irgendwas
ist. Aber bleibt einfach nicht aus, ab einer gewissen Größe, wenn du da einen Furz lässt,
schreien irgendwelche Leute rum.
Der Shitstorm ist so groß geworden, dass sich dann danach kaum ein Hersteller mehr getraut
hat, solche Mechaniken in ihr Premiumspiel einzubauen und daraus entstand dann einfach
ein Rückgang dieser offensiven Lootboxen oder Predatory Business, sagt man eigentlich. Das
traut sich heute kein großer Spielehersteller mehr und deswegen ist es ein bisschen seltener
geworden.
Ja, dafür verstecken Sie jetzt irgendwelche komischen Dinger drin.
Lichtblick, aber in vielen Teilen der Industrie sind Lootboxen weiterverbreitet denn je. Dazu
gehört auch drei Jahre später immer noch FIFA. Aber es gibt bei Ultimate Team doch
neben den regulären...
Dafür verstecken Sie jetzt Dinger. Du hast jetzt einen Season Pass, wo du die Level frei
kaufen kannst. Es wird nie wieder weggehen, das ist sicher. Es wird eher mehr und noch
versteckter und die lernen ja auch dazu. Also quasi mit jedem Fail, also man freut sich
ja immer, man freut sich ja immer, wenn irgendwie ein Hersteller es mal richtig verkackt hat.
Sei es jetzt mit Battlefront 2 oder sonst was, dann denkt man ja, boll, bam, ihr seht
ja mal, die können sich immer noch übertreiben. In Wirklichkeit ist es so, aus jedem Fail,
wo es nicht geklappt hat, lernen die Hersteller ja. Die sind ja nicht blöd. Die machen vielleicht
keine guten Games mehr, aber das können sie. Da sitzen wirklich big brain Leute dran. Aus
jedem Fail wird ja da gelernt, um es dann besser zu machen. Das heißt irgendwann kriegen
die das so gut hin, dass es keiner mehr checkt und sich jeder das Geld aus den Taschen ziehen
lässt.
Jetzt auch sogenannte Preview Packs. Dort kann man einmal alle 24 Stunden sehen, was
im Pack drin ist, bevor man es kauft.
Also es sieht nicht aus wie eine Lootbox, oder? Aber es ist ein Konzern, dass das, was
die Leute an Geld stecken, nicht in ihrer aktuellen, geöffneten Lootbox ist, sondern
in der nächsten Lootbox. Also du gammelst auf der nächsten Lootbox in der Live.
War es nicht so bei den CS Lootboxen, dass sie das irgendwie verboten haben und du hast
dann gesehen, was drin ist, aber du musstest dir dann trotzdem, die hatten doch richtig
big brain System, seitdem die Lootboxen verboten haben mit CS. Ich krieg das nicht mal zusammen.
Das neue System war quasi noch heftiger als das alte.
Dr. David Sandel, ein führender Wissenschaftler auf dem Gebiet der Videospiel-Monetarisierung.
Ultimate Team ist zwar oberflächlich betrachtet...
Du konntest reinschauen, aber keine neue kaufen, wenn du nicht angenommen hast. Genau, genau,
du konntest reinschauen, aber du musstest quasi, ja sowas.
... geworden, aber aus Sicht von Sandel ist es wahrscheinlich nur ein Trick, um Regulierung
zu umgehen.
Ach.
Denn man wettet immer noch, nur halt auf den folgenden Inhalt, nicht den momentanen.
It's really easy to explain to a government how a vanilla player pack corresponds with
gambling.
These novel preview packs, the mechanism appears like it might be exactly the same, but the
explanation is much more hard.
Den Modus Ultimate Team gibt es natürlich auch noch in anderen großen Sportspielen
von EA.
Gemeinsam sind die Ultimate Team Spielmodi verantwortlich für fast 30% des gesamten
Umsatzes von EA.
FIFA Ultimate Team allein macht nach Schätzungen...
Richtig, man hat sich damals schon aufgeregt, wenn es irgendeine OP-Waffe nur in einem DLC
gab.
Heute ist das vollkommen Standard.
... ca. 16% aus.
Sehr überspitzt.
Wenn man Lootboxen als Glücksspiel betrachtet, wäre EAs Business zu fast ein Drittel ein
Casino.
Nice.
Wir haben EA mit den Bedenken von Forschern wie Dr.
Sandel konfrontiert.
EA betont, dass die Gesetzgebung in vielen Ländern zu dem Schluss gekommen ist, dass
Lootboxen kein Glücksspiel darstellen, weil man nicht direkt Geld gewinnen kann.
Das ist auch die Sichtweise der Firma.
EA schreibt zusätzlich, dass es keinen schlussendlichen wissenschaftlichen Konsens gebe, ob Lootboxen
wirklich gefährlich sind.
EA hat uns außerdem versichert, dass minderjährige FIFA-Spieler im Median nur 37,20 Euro pro
Jahr für Ultimate Team ausgeben.
Ach ja.
Ein anderes Beispiel wäre Genshin Impact.
Das ist ein Adventure-Rollenspiel mit Lootbox-Mechaniken, das letztes Jahr ein riesiger Hit war.
Der YouTuber Emtesht hat rund 1.700 Euro verzockt, beim Versuch einen bestimmten Genshin Impact
Kumpel zu ziehen.
Das ist natürlich ordentlich.
Das hat ihn dazu verleitet, sich öffentlich bei allen seinen Zuschauern zu entschuldigen
und komplett aufzuhören, Geld in dem Spiel auszugeben.
So.
Richtig.
Das ist gut.
Normalerweise wäre es jetzt so.
Das ist genau so ein Beispiel, was ich meine.
Also der hat anscheinend wirklich ein bisschen Brain und hat drüber nachgedacht.
Das ist jetzt der Punkt, wo du dich entscheiden musst zwischen ich konfrontiere mich selbst
mit der Realität, ich habe 1.700 Euro quasi verbrannt.
Das ist ja quasi die Realität.
Und jetzt ist halt die Frage an dieser Stelle.
Sagst du jetzt, fuck, das war eine dofe Idee, ich passe jetzt in Zukunft besser auf, eventuell
mache ich ein Video drüber und sage Leute, lass den Scheiß sein oder aber, und das ist
wahrscheinlich das, wo sich 90% der Leute für entscheiden werden, zu sagen, hey, ist
doch alles gar nicht so schlimm.
Ich mache weiter damit.
Die meisten Leute wollen sich das nicht eingestehen.
Es ist für viele Leute, und ich kann das ja auch verstehen, es ist unglaublich schwierig,
sich einzugestehen, wenn man quasi es aus freien Stücken verschissen hat.
Also es hat dich ja niemand dazu gezwungen.
Wenn es irgendwie Ausreden gibt, zu sagen, dass jemand anderes dran schuld ist, dann
macht man das ja immer.
Dann sagt man, ja, ich kann da nichts dafür, irgendwer da, das ist schuld.
Aber wenn es so offensichtlich klar ist, dass man es selbst verkackt hat, dann fällt es
den Leuten, und ich kann es ja auch verstehen, unglaublich schwer, sich das einzugestehen,
und jetzt an der Stelle würden bestimmt 90% der Leute sagen, ach, ist doch nicht so schlimm,
jetzt habe ich endlich das, was ich haben will, jetzt mache ich ein bisschen weiter, spiele
ich das gerne noch weiter, ich habe so viel Geld reingesteckt schon, und die planten
das komplett aus, dass sie 1700 Euro verbrannt haben.
Okay, dass er jetzt anfängt zu weinen im Video ist vielleicht ein bisschen zu vieles
gut, aber...
Muss mittlerweile jedes Video, wo irgendetwas emotionales überzeugt ist, müssen die Leute
dann anfangen zu weinen auf YouTube?
Der Typ ist eh durch, von dem habe ich schon ein paar Highlights gesehen, der ist echt
durch.
Alter...
Der ist voll durch.
Okay, die allermeisten Menschen betrifft das alles nicht, mit hoher Wahrscheinlichkeit
hast du noch keine paar tausend Euro in ein Spiel gepumpt, für dich, mich und viele andere
sind Spiele mit Lootboxen und anderen Mikrotransaktionen einfach nur nervig, die meisten Spieler hätten
lieber keine Ingame-Verkäufe, so ist es halt, doch darauf zielen diese Geschäftsmodelle
auch gar nicht ab, nein, die Entwickler jagen Wale, gerade im Mobile-Gaming-Bereich macht
ein verschwindend geringer Teil der Spieler den Großteil des Umsatzes auf, ganz genaue
Zahlen gibt es nicht, aber meist sind das irgendwo zwischen 0,1 und 2% der Spieler,
da gab es ja mal so einen witzigen Bericht drüber, von irgendeinem Mobile-Game und die
sind ja dann so weit gegangen, also die sind ja wirklich big brain, ich glaube das war,
vielleicht war sogar ein Artikel in der GameStar, ich weiß nicht, zumindest hat da irgendein
Entwickler drüber berichtet, ne das war auf Englisch, das kann doch in der GameStar gewesen
sein, egal, die haben darüber berichtet, wie sie das gemacht haben, sie haben festgestellt,
dass die halt ein paar Leute haben, die besonders gut bezahlen und darauf hin sind die, pass
mal auf, darauf hin haben die die Leute analysiert, was die gerne haben, das ging dann so weit,
dass man auf die Facebook-Seiten der Leute ist und sich geguckt hat, was mögen die und
dann haben die festgestellt, ah, der Typ kauft alles in Orange, weil sein Lieblings-Fußball-Verein
quasi orangenes Trikot hat, so nach dem Motto, also Orange ist so sein Lieblings-Verein,
die sind dann auf Facebook, so und darauf hin haben die explizit Items in das Game eingebaut,
die quasi orange waren und irgendwie angelehnt waren an den Lieblings-Fußball-Club von diesem
Typ, ohne dass sie Lizenzgebühren dafür bezahlen mussten oder so, also so gezielt wurde das
da gemacht.
Tausende, teils Zehntausende Euro in ein Spiel pumpen, es gibt lange Analysen und AI-Tools,
wie man sein Spiel optimieren muss, um diese Wale zu fangen und gezielt dazu zu bringen,
immer mehr Geld auszugeben.
Der Vortrag aus Kapitel 1 heißt zum Beispiel tatsächlich, Let's Go Wailing.
Es geht nicht darum, eine Alkohol.
Alter, was mit der Musik im Hintergrund los jetzt übertreibt, das macht ja immer wahnsinnig
Drama draus.
Für tausend Euro anzubieten.
Spiele sollten so gestaltet werden, dass man jeden Tag aufs Neue eine kleine bis mittlere
Summe Geld ausgeben kann.
Unlimited upper spend.
Geil.
Aber das Narrativ in der Industrie ist häufig, diese Leute hätten das Geld ja übrig.
Das sieht die Wissenschaft ganz anders.
Spieler, die zum Beispiel viele Lootboxen kaufen, sind nicht reich.
Es gibt Anzeichen, dass diese Menschen teils schlügt und einfach...
Wisst ihr, was eines der traurigsten Sachen war, die ich so in diesem Zusammenhang, hat
jetzt nicht direkt mit Mobile Games, die ich gelesen hab, dass einer der Top-Donator von
ich glaube Ninja, als er noch auf Twitch war, könnte auch DrDisrespect gewesen sein, aber
ich glaube es war Ninja, einer der Top-Donator.
Das war ein ganz armer Sack im Endeffekt, der Aufmerksamkeit quasi dadurch generieren
wollte, stimmt, er ist wieder auf Twitch, dass er eben als der große Gönner in Twitch-Streams
ist.
Er hat auch bei The Friend Donated und sonst wie, also den kannte man vom Namen her, der
hat, so und am Ende kam raus, der Typ hatte nicht sonderlich viel Geld, der hatte wohl
irgendeine Auszahlung bekommen oder so und was weiß ich, von irgendeiner Versicherung
oder sowas, muss man mal genauer nachgucken, ich krieg's nicht mal genau zusammen, zumindest
der Punkt, worauf ich raus will, der Kerl hat sich quasi in so einem Rausch Donated auf
Twitch und am Ende kam das ganze nur raus, dass das gar kein Ölscheich ist oder so,
weil der hat sich auch immer so als super reicher Gönner hingestellt, also er fand
das cool, dass Twitch ihn quasi so als Ölscheich ansieht und am Ende kam die ganze Sache bloß
raus, weil seine Frau auf Facebook geschrieben hat, der Typ ist im Krankenhaus und ist schwer
krank und kann die Krankenhausrechnung nicht bezahlen, weil das Geld, was er hatte, hat
er alles verdonatet und die Versicherung oder nee oder was weiß ich, Versicherung und also
sprich das, wo er jetzt eigentlich das bezahlen könnte, hat er auch nicht mehr, weil er so
viel donatet hat, das ist eigentlich schon krass oder, das war echt eines der bittersten
Geschichten, die ich in dieser Richtung je gelesen hab, aber es ist relativ ähnlich,
der hat halt in irgendeiner Art und Weise Glücksgefühle, Bestätigung, was weiß ich,
dadurch bekommen, dass er sich auf Twitter sehen, als der krasse Ölscheich hinstellen
konnte oder was auch immer er da war und gehuldigt wurde von den Leuten und das fand der halt
nice und das hat ihn so weit motiviert, dass er alles quasi dafür ausgegeben hat.
Problemspieler sind Menschen mit einer Glücksspielsucht, die unkontrolliert immer mehr Geld ausgeben,
obwohl sie es häufig eigentlich nicht übrig haben. Aber ganz genau weiß man das nicht,
einfach weil Spieleentwickler ihre Daten so gut wie nie mit Forschern wie Dr. Sandel
teilen. Vielleicht aus Angst, was er und andere über die wahre Natur der Wale herausfinden.
Hey, einfach weil es Geld bringt. Was die rausfinden ist dir wahrscheinlich relativ
egal, weil es bei den Spielern ähnlich ankommt. Die Daten sind pure, pure, pures Money für
die.
Natürlich sind nicht alle Spiele so aufgebaut und nicht jeder Entwickler ist derart auf
Profite um jeden Preis aus. Viele Next-Gen-Games sind in jeder Hinsicht absolute Meisterwerke,
dazu kommen zahllose tolle Indie-Spiele. Etliche Free-To-Play-Titel sind toll umgesetzt und
finanzieren sich sehr erfolgreich auf faire Art und Weise. Doch die Videospielindustrie
wächst immer, immer weiter. Sie ist heute schon größer als die Musik- und Filmindustrie
zusammen.
Das wissen viele gar nicht. Gerade die älteren Semester haben auch gemerkt, dass Gaming
mittlerweile viel mehr in der Gesellschaft angekommen ist. Aber das ist denen glaube
ich gar nicht klar.
Und Mikrotransaktionen machen einen immer größeren Anteil.
Und Blizzard schrumpft. Da ist aber Blizzard selbst dran schuld.
...des Umsatzes aus. Letztes Jahr war es schon über 20%. Noch deutlicher macht es der Umsatz
des Industriegiganten Activision Blizzard. Innerhalb von nur sieben Jahren sind Microtransactions
und Abos das Hauptgeschäft des Unternehmens geworden. Bei vielen Entwicklern ist die Verlockung
vermutlich groß, die Spiele richtig heftig durchzumonetarisieren. Denn es funktioniert
ganz offensichtlich. Genshin Impact ist ein unglaublicher finanzieller Erfolg. Es hat
diese Art von Free-To-Play-Lootbox-Spiel auf die Konsole gebracht. Andere werden versuchen,
das zu reproduzieren.
Das war auch der Grund, warum ich das nie gespielt habe. Ich habe das System dahinter
erfahren, habe ich mir gedacht, nö, kein Bock.
Obwohl das Spiel an sich eigentlich gar nicht schlecht ist. Als ich das gehört habe, so
ist das Monetarisierungssystem dahinter. Ich habe gesagt, nö, ich spiele nicht. Warum
soll ich das machen?
Im Team ist finanziell so wichtig für EA, dass der Konzern es sich überhaupt nicht
erlauben kann, den Modus grundlegend zu verändern. Das steht tatsächlich in etwas anderen Worten
im letzten Jahresbericht des Entwicklers. Sind diese Geschäftsmodelle wirklich nachhaltig?
Spiele, die sich über die Ausbeutung einiger weniger Menschen finanzieren? Man könnte
sich zumindest in diesem Extremfall selbst regulieren. Zum Beispiel mit Limits, wie viel
ein Spieler in einem Game ausgebe.
Warum sollten die sich selbst regulieren? Das ist aber nicht Stonks. Das ist denen doch
scheißegal. Aus moralischer Sicht hat er natürlich vollkommen recht. Aber das ist den Stonks-Leuten
doch vollkommen egal. Die würden auch ihre Mutter ausbeuten, das ist denen doch wurscht.
Abseits davon muss man bei Lootboxen über Altersbeschränkungen reden. Immer und überall
klar angezeigte Gewinnchancen und Preise in Echtgeld. Am Ende geht es um die Frage,
was...
Klar angezeigte Gewinnchancen, das ist schon das erste, wo man tricksen kann. Dann schreibst
du hin, 80% Gewinnchance. Und dann guckst du, was du zu 80% bekommst. Ja gut, ein Gold.
Mit einem Gold kannst du nichts anfangen. Niemand scrollt dann runter eine Liste mit
300 Wahrscheinlichkeiten, was du bekommen kannst und sowas.
Games sein wollen. Vehikel für fragwürdige Praktiken, um Geld zu verdienen. Fangenetze
für anfällige Personen, die man dann ganz eklig Wale tauft. Oder Produkte, Kunstwerke,
die wirklich Geld wert sind.
Es ist ja nicht so, dass sich alles in Richtung Lootboxen bewegt oder sowas. Es ist halt nur
recht viel und es sind auch leider sehr populäre Spiele.
Es gibt durchaus noch gute Games.
Im Grunde kannst du dich ja wirklich überall austoben. Du kannst ja überall Sachen finden
und bist gar nicht eingeschränkt. Ist ja nicht so, als wäre der Korydor nur aus Lootbox-Games.
Es gibt aber halt, ja. Es gibt halt einfach viele. Und das sind eben die, die auch in
your face überall dastehen. Wer macht Werbung? Raid Shadow Legends? Nicht irgendwer? What
the fuck? Nein, ich will nix über Funk wissen.
Ok, Alter. So, kurz Musik anmachen.
Das ist wie AGB, die liest man. Ja, so ungefähr.
Raid Shadow Legends. Also, man muss ja sagen, Geld haben die genug. Die waren ja bei mir
auch schon am Start. Und ich weiß es nicht, weil ich hab's irgendwann mal im Stream erzählt.
Ich glaub 1500 Euro oder irgendwas. Einfach so für meinen Popel-Stream. Ja. Für irgendwie
ne Stunde zeigen oder so. Also das war schon echt nicht ohne. Und dann irgendwie noch
eine Beteiligung an Downloads und sowas. Also die schmeißen Geld raus wie nix.
Aber mit denen werd ich nix machen.
So. Was kommen wir uns jetzt als nächstes an? Zeig mal her. Ich habe mein 12.090k gekennet.
Oh ne, ne. Kein New World Flame. Also wir müssen uns glaub ich heute kein New World
Flame Video angucken, weil, weil, Sekunde. Die New World Steam Stats sprechen für sich.
Innerhalb der ersten paar Wochen, Alter. Tja, ich hab's euch gesagt, Leute. Februar
gucken wir mal. Mal gucken, ob ich recht hab. Es sieht aber alles so aus, wenn das, es sieht
sogar so aus, als geht es noch schneller als ich das mir ursprünglich mal gedacht hätte.
Die sind runter, die sind runter von ungefähr 900.000 auf Dings. Also die haben die Hälfte
der Spieler, ums jetzt mal schön zu rechnen sogar noch mehr. Also die haben quasi 55%
der Spieler verloren in den ersten paar Wochen. Das ist schon krass. Vor allem hatte das halt
einen hohen Anspruch. Hast du schon von den Bugs mit der Schadensberechnung gelesen? Ja,
klar, da gibt es nicht nur Bugs mit der Schadensberechnung, von Gold Duplication Bugs bis Unlimited Sprint
und alles, alles kannst du vergessen. Also New World ist so extremst broken. Das werden
die auch nicht mehr auf die Reihe kriegen. Kann ich mir nicht vorstellen. PC am Straßenrand
gewohnt. Das ist doch bestimmt Fake, oder? Das ist doch bestimmt Fake. Fage. Ich mein,
eigentlich ist das eine richtig Big Brain Idee. Also gehen wir jetzt, ich will ihm nicht unterstellen,
dass es Fake ist. Wahrscheinlich ist es legit. Aber nur mal von der Theorie her, eigentlich
wäre das eine Big Brain Idee. So könnte man Easy Videos generieren. Du nimmst dir einfach
einen alten Rechner irgendwo her, sagst keine Ahnung, am Straßenrand gefunden, ob das stimmt
oder nicht. Wer will das nachvollziehen? Das kennen wir schon. Dann weiß ich nicht. Amazon,
Philips Hue, 10 Jahre. Haben wir die Battlefield Top Plays geguckt hier schon vor letztem
Mal? Ich glaube nicht, oder? Extrem dreckiger Raucher-PC. Aber was habe ich denn da drauf
gemacht? Okay, ich will mir das Video nicht angucken. Ich will mal bloß gucken, was extrem
dreckig bedeutet. Gelb halt. Okay, wie sieht das Ding von innen aus? Tomtricks, danke
für den Sub. Ja, es ist halt gelber Staub, aber ansonsten, ist halt ver, ver, ver, äh,
EU, weg damit. So, ähm, haben wir das Battlefield Top Plays schon geguckt? Sekunde, Chat, was
ist, was? Hat mir letztens eine FritzBorg 7500 im Wald Fahrradweg gefunden. Achja, ziemlich
demütigiert, aber auch, um sich in die Läufe wunderbar und bin dann dreimal lang gelaufen,
um die Gehäuse teilen zu finden. Ja klar. Chat, Chat ist der Umwelt zuliebe wieder unterwegs,
ja. Das haben wir schon gesehen? Haben wir das schon gesehen? Wirklich? Ah ja, das haben
wir schon gesehen. Das haben wir schon gesehen. Jaja, das kommt mir bekannt vor. Ja, das haben
wir schon gesehen. Das haben wir schon gesehen. Okay, gibt es irgendwas Neues? Äh, nein, gibt
nichts Neues. Ja, gut. So langweilig. So, YouTube, ich brauch irgendwas noch. Boomer-Gedächtnis,
ja, ich kann mir das nicht alles merken. Okay, dann gucken wir uns das Video vom Bauer an.
Mit der dicken Katze davor, jawoll. Wobei, ich glaube, das ist gar nicht sonderlich spannend.
Ich meine, wahrscheinlich hat er seine CPU irgendwie zu krass übertaktet und dann, das
ist nicht so superspannend. Äh, ja, was gucken wir denn jetzt? Mir fällt jetzt, tja. Er hat
eine Schraube draufgeschmissen. F. Also, Firearms Experts React möchte mir, dass YouTube wirklich
aufs Auge drücken, ne? Was, das Amazon ist echt gut. Wie lang ist das, Zack? Du meinst
das hier, was der Chat gerade gepostet hat? Eine Stunde 53, nein, das gucken wir jetzt
ganz bestimmt nicht. Wir können Inside Amazons Massive Data Center gucken. Gucken, was da
rauskommt. Tinder, jawoll. Ja. Ja, jetzt übertreibts mal nicht.
ich gucke immer gerne, was die auf den Displays haben. Ah, man sieht nix. Man
sieht nix. Das ist leider zu unscharf. Ich frage mich immer, ob das fake ist. Gibt es
wirklich Leute, die ohne Maus arbeiten im Büro? Das ist doch alles fake, oder? Niemand arbeitet
ohne Maus. Vor allem nicht mit zwei Monitoren und wenn man viel im Browser unterwegs ist.
Oh, die Hacker-Menschen am Start hier.
Okay, das ist Video für Ultra-Noobs, oder? Ich mein, Inside Massive Data Center, aktuell
sehe ich da irgendwelche Stocks-Video, Stock-Video-Footage. Das ist ja Pains-Champ. Okay, das ist sinnlos.
Das ist sinnlos. Richtig sinnlos. Matchy Baited als bei Levelcap, ja. Echt so. Hallo, YouTube,
please, Startzeit. Jetzt ist auch noch YouTube gecrasht. Leute, mein Tab ist gecrasht. So
ResidentSleeper war das Video. Gibt es nicht irgendwas Gescheites, was wir noch gucken
können? Mensch, YouTube, irgendwas Kurzes vielleicht? Angespannte Corona-Lage in Russland,
ist mir vollkommen egal. Why did Facebook go down? Ja, das haben wir uns ja sogar zusammen
im Stream schon angeschaut. Also nicht das Video, sondern was das Problem war. De Natur
Lüberg. Ich weiß noch nicht mal, wo Lüberg ist. Irgendwo an der Nordsee, oder? Keine
Ahnung, wo ist Lüberg? Ostsee? Da war ich doch schon mal gar nicht verkehrt. Die Richtung
stimmte. Ich glaube nicht, dass Wayland irgendwie was Gescheites noch wird. X ist aber auch
Müll. Zuschauer PC vom Blitz getroffen. Jetzt übertreiben sie. Also macht jetzt PewDiePie
hier auf MrBeast irgendwelche Challenges. Meine Güte, gibt es irgendwelche gescheiten
Videos zur Abwechslung nochmal? Der Tesla-Bot ist ein schlechter Witz. What the fuck? Also
da klickt man doch auch noch wegen dem Subtile drauf, oder? Das haben wir schon geguckt.
Oh Mann. Es gibt nichts zu gucken, Leute. Das ist ja schlimm. New Beautiful Smart Home
Gadgets. Ja, da ist wahrscheinlich... Das ist doch der Typ, der in jedem zweiten Satz
sagt Alexa, oder? Was ist denn mit YouTube gerade los? Warum ist denn das so broken? Was
ist denn hier? Der Browser ist komplett Gegenteil von Vogue. Der ist kaputt. Ja, der Browser
ist kaputt. Was ist denn im Arsch? Was ist denn das hier? Meine Güte. Geht dann irgendwas
anderes auf? Ne, mein Browser ist kaputt. Okay, Null. Was ist, wenn ich sage New Window?
Was du? Warum ist mein Chrome im Arsch? Okay, ich glaube, es wird Zeit einfach mal alles
auszumachen. Ah, jetzt geht's wieder. Okay, excellent, excellent. Jetzt die Musik ist
ein wenig laut. Okay, nice. Tja, Leute, es gibt nichts zu gucken. Es ist nur Müll. Wir
können auch die anderen drei Videos gucken, aber ehrlich gesagt gehen alle so lang. Du
musst mir Ram-Downdownen. Leute, ich weiß, was ich mache. Ich muss noch ein Battlefield-Video
aufnehmen. Habe ich mir jetzt ein paar Tage vorgedrückt. Dadurch, dass wir heute schon
schön früh online waren, kann ich jetzt noch ein Battlefield-Video für Mittag aufnehmen.
So mache ich das. Ich gehe jetzt auf und nehme ein Battlefield-Video auf. Und ich nehme
schon die ganze Zeit machen. Dann lad ich das nachher rauf. Ich habe jetzt schon wieder
eine Woche oder so nichts hochgeladen mit Echtzeit. Ja, können jetzt weiter pennen, Leute. Wir
sehen uns. Bis denn, CU.